the biden admin just keeps uh
saying the quiet part loud jenn sackey
recently said that they were working
with facebook
to flag misinformation as if the
government has the authority to
determine what is true and what is false
they don't
well that's exactly what's happening
facebook is taking people down they've
been censoring and this is basically the
government admitting that they are using
private actors to censor american speech
and then uh she put her foot in her
mouth again or i guess actually took it
out because they're
saying the quiet part loud gensake came
out and said
that you should be banned from all
platforms
for misinformation if you're banned on
one
and this was such an alarming statement
to come from the federal government from
the executive branch
that even leftists are going whoa whoa
whoa i mean but a private company but
come on there yeah this is what we've
all been warning out for
warning about for a long time but i
think that too many people on the left
were like well it's not negatively
impacting me so i'm gonna be fine with
it and now it's got to the point where
the government is straight up like
if you say something bad you should be
purged from the internet completely
and that's where we're at so we're going
to talk about that we're going to chill
we got a lot of stuff to talk about man
with with government corruption we've
got uh
war issues to talk about with what's
going on with south africa and and cuba
of course
but then we've also got uh the the the
threat of balkanization here in the us
so i actually did the math
yesterday we talked about the the you
know percentage of people in the us who
wanted to balkanize and i said it was
over 35
i did the hard numbers because i
mentioned that
when you each region is not the same
population i went through the went right
through the populations
multiplied divided all that good stuff
37.2 percent based on this poll
of the united states wants it to
balkanize that is more than a third that
is that is substantial in my opinion
so we got to talk about what this means
and uh it's friday so we're usually
chilling
so uh of course we're hanging out today
with force cooper of recoil mag hey
you wanna introduce yourself yeah so my
name is force cooper uh as you said i am
with recoil magazine
here here's an example of what we do i
run guns yeah
gun stuff right so we've got chris chang
on the cover shout out to chris chang
uh if you're familiar with people like
maj turay you'll you kind of know the
people that we deal with
and uh so we are a gun lifestyle
magazine
and then i myself uh background in
military special operations
and now i am here and and the editor of
the team
that i really enjoy what's going on
you've been on the ground a lot of these
riots too haven't you yeah well i live
in minneapolis so i think being on the
ground is just
you live in the rocks obligatory i guess
yeah and and don't worry
you know if in case you haven't known
they're still going on in minneapolis
they're just
no one wants to talk about anymore
because it's old news yeah or it's not
good for
i don't know you don't get anything out
of it i guess we'll we'll get into all
that stuff we've got
chilling what's up dog ian crossland
over here you're happy to be here
glad you're here for us we did a little
uh adventure earlier picking up oh yeah
you guys are picking berries yeah we're
making wine wine
yeah wine berry wine it's actually just
called wine wine you know
yeah it's like like a very normal thing
that people like
wine wine with wine forest went deep he
went beyond the perimeter
to get into the real where all the
berries really were
yeah they're like juicy and plump oh man
yeah i had to i had to wash my hands for
a solid minute
um and yes of course the ranger did go
into
the woods that's right you know so find
berries
yeah you know shout out to mountain
phase they don't want to starve to death
right on good policy i am also here in
the corner i got my little cameo earlier
um and i'm excited for tonight's
conversation always love having forrest
here i know we look like siblings you
don't need to say it it's true
we'll uh we'll see how the conversation
goes tonight before we get started my
friends go over to timcast.com become a
member
and you'll get access to exclusive
members only segments of the tim cast
irl podcast as well as
you'll be supporting our intrepid and
fearless journalists as they begin
reporting on the affairs of the world
however what you see on the screen is
something special
this is the new website which is coming
up and there's a lot of things that you
can't actually see just from
the image but uh this is our soft target
is monday
a lot of the hard work and heavy lifting
will be done over the weekend and then
by monday this should be live
you can see how amazing it is the
articles excuse me
we have on the left here you can see
okay you can't see too much but we have
a channel section my head is blocking it
and all of our different shows are going
to appear there and this site's going to
be fantastic one of the plans that we
have is
if you are a member and you don't like
one of the shows
you can just literally click a button in
your settings and it won't appear on
your on the front page anymore so you
can actually curate the topics you care
about
like tech news or culture or politics so
you could actually set the website to
only see
like culture war stuff about movies and
video games or only politics or both or
the paranormal stuff we're building this
to be like a multi-function
news and media website with tons of
shows and that's because
you know when we launched the website i
was like we could get banned from all of
these payment
you know these subscription services so
we better make our own website
and then all of a sudden we got so many
people signing up right away that i was
like
okay this is this is a lot of people we
got to do way more than just
have like this single website it was
effectively like a private patreon kind
of thing
so uh here we are now it's been six
months since we launched the site and we
already have this like really powerful
in my opinion it's revolutionary it's
gonna be much like youtube subscriptions
combined with the news
we're doing all this awesome stuff
that's what it's going to look like
there's going to be a lot more we've got
i think six or seven writers already
we hired like four more people to run
the vlog so we're gonna have multiple
shows we have animators we have a video
game in the works
this is crazy we're it's all thanks to
you guys who are members you guys rock
so that's this is you can see it here
this is what being a member is helping
build
and you can see some of the stories
there we got rhonda santa's calls on
cuban military to rebel we got tons of
work being done so again
sign up become a member but don't forget
to like
share subscribe share this video with
your friends if you think it's a good
show that's the best thing you can do
that's how we
we beat the algorithms and we beat the
censorship and my friends
this story is literally about how the
federal government is saying that for
one
they're going to be colluding or they
are colluding with big tech we've got
statements from facebook that apparently
they were communicating with the bite
administration
and now we have them saying oh you
should be banned from every platform if
you're banned from one
that's why it's important you share this
video but let's jump into this first
story and talk about the apocalypse how
about that
we got fox news twitter explodes after
saki urges big tech to unite
on bands for misinformation spreaders
this
is white house directed collusion
remarking on steps social media outlets
could take for public health she advised
they quote
create robust enforcement strategies
that bridge their properties
and provide transparency about rules you
shouldn't be banned from one platform
and not others if you're providing
misinformation
here's what's important do you guys know
what misinformation means
uh no there's disinformation you'll hear
them say it
and there's misinformation
disinformation they define as
intentionally misleading people you're
it's dis-info you're you're going to
them and telling them wrong things you
know are wrong to screw with them right
misinformation is when you're just wrong
so you could be like
um that dog is called a chihuahua when
it's actually a dachshund and then
they're going to be like that's
misinformation
i don't i'm not going to give her the
benefit the benefit of the doubt on this
one i think she genuinely means
if you go on social media and say
something that is incorrect you should
be purged from every platform
that's on top of the fact that we're
learning now they're literally
colluding that that gensake said i think
i think i have this uh this story right
here
check this out newsweek biden
administration's admission
their flagging content to facebook
sparks fewer now there's a mistake here
in the title jen seki did not say we are
flagging content to facebook
she said for facebook this is
the federal government instructing
private actors
to violate the rights of individuals as
i explained yesterday it's really simple
the federal government can't hire a
private security company to go and shut
down a church
because that's the government shutting
down the church
this is this is what this is where we're
at it's dark days man
i'm afraid of what the definition of
misinformation will be tomorrow
whatever i don't want you to say yeah
clearly
if they're flagging misinformation
they're asserting that they're the
arbiters of truth this has been the
the freakiest thing i've seen
um since obama re-signed the ndaa i
think
well so they do the ndaa every year but
since
it was publicly acknowledged that obama
was signing a provision that would allow
the u.s to
effectively rendition anyone anywhere
for any reason indefinitely
yeah you'd be sleeping in your bed and
they'll be like
a black bag i'm wondering too if you
provide
misinformation and forget your mom's
middle name or something on facebook
does that mean you're gonna get banned
off of like godaddy too
so like yes all not just social media
but every platform everywhere like what
does that even mean mailchimp
your telephone number your bank account
you'll effectively get disappeared
digital disappearing no just this well i
mean how
how different is it from actually
disappearing somebody when you have no
access to resources anymore i
got to be honest though this actually
it's scary it's brazen
but i think it's actually kind of a good
thing you know why no
it's so overt and insane yeah it can't
work
yeah i mean we have crypto technology
man so there she's like we'll ban you
from everything if you start doing that
if you start purging everyone from every
platform for your misinformation
then all you're going to do is create
market competition and decentralize
networks
because look if if they i mean
they'd have to they would have to take a
light touch but if they ban people like
especially if they banned a show like
like ours and then purged all of us from
social media who's like well you know
tim said misinformation they're all on
the show and got rid of everybody
we're not going to cease to exist that's
why we made timcast.com
so i guess the the web hosts will then
come after us then we'll do what gab did
we'll make our own server we'll make our
own browser we'll make our own
our own network systems right so so you
were sorry
i don't mean interrupt i was listening
to dave smith earlier today on part of
the problem
shout out to dave we love dave over here
um and he was talking about the way she
is being
two over and he talks about how
sometimes they'll overreach and tim
calls us
scott adams calls us selling past the
point they're like over
asking the big ask whatever it is um and
if they do it too much
people start to notice and they freak
out right so they'll back it up
back it up back in a little bit i think
yeah exactly and jill biden was talking
about how
jenn saki is really messing this up
because she's about to leave right she's
like
you know fleeing the sinking ship or
whatever she's retiring um and i think
she's
she's kind of messing it up for them
because she is overselling it and now
they're going to have to walk it back so
i think we can expect to see that
what they do is they'll say i want ten
okay fine seven mm-hmm you know you got
a can of coke worth a dollar and it's
the big ask it's what trump did
okay yeah let's use another example
that's very uh that i have
in intimate relationship with it's
firearms okay we want to ban ar-15s no
uh why why won't you compromise okay
we'll only we'll limit you to 10-round
magazines
well that seems like an okay compromise
like and that's why when you see this
whole
it's republicans in a nutshell dude yeah
i mean it's it's exactly the same thing
like why do you think so many people are
frustrated with the
state of uh the defense of the second
amendment right now it's because
when did we win last and the
but there's a good side of this we're
winning the culture
right so that's for sure no second
amendment people oh yeah no we're like
the top of the town talk of the town
right now yeah like we are winning the
culture
the second amendment is winning i mean i
even wrote an article on it about a year
ago
saying like the second amendment is
alive and well because people are
realizing that their
access to firearms should not be
restricted by the government
what's what's really amazing to me about
the about this fight particular with
with the republicans is that
in in what way is it a compromise to
accept
10 percent of the standard magazine
capacity or are you or
do you mean uh 30 000 that was a half no
no 10 10 percent of the standard makers
oh yeah i mean the standard magazine
because it's like a hundred round drum
yeah easy yeah
[Laughter]
i mean because who are you trying to
appease like
you got to make deals with good faith
actors what i'm doing there is quite
literally the point
you say well 100 rounds is standard well
ten percent that's too low okay
we'll do 50. how's 50 because that's
half of where we're at right
right then you just end up where it's
like i don't recognize your right to
tell me that i can and cannot own things
and then
here's another good example of how
that's turning out too so
what what happens when the government
decides
you know we've already seen uh whether
it's dave chipman
didn't bring that sticker up here that's
great oh yeah i think i don't think we
can show that stuff
no we can't show that oops but so you
know you've got
elements of waco yeah oh yeah dave
chipman uh
this move in the atf to ban braces uh
read the article um atf braceband
explained because
the braceband itself is convoluted and
then also
the kind of attack on home-built
firearms or 80 firearms
uh two states hawaii and nevada have
retroactively banned the ownership of
those
well well so i don't want to get too off
topic because this is fairly optimistic
stuff and i don't want people in the
audience to feel too good about what's
going on so let's go back to are we
are we winning that same fight and i'm
joking by the way but when it comes to
the speech stuff
jen seki's going over the top like
that's why i said i think this might be
like if imagine if the federal
government came out and said we're going
to ban literally
well they actually did this they wanted
to ban all semi-autos remember that yep
that was the funniest thing when i was
at the march for our lives
and people were like semi-automatic
weapons should be banned and i was like
so you think like the weapon a police
officer uses and they were like oh no
not like a handgun i'm like those are
semi-auto
so anyway to sort of lump these together
because we got the first and second
amendments kind of sitting next to each
other
they're they're they're necessarily tied
to one another one without the other is
impotent
and the other without the one has no aim
oh i think the second amendment is the
most important one though
yeah and and the and the first amendment
doesn't matter if you don't have the
second and the second one has no
direction if you don't have the first
well what do you mean by that so like
what's the point like oh and instructing
people and informing them
keeping right is necessary like our
ability to speak to one another i would
much rather have a conversation with you
that's a good point if you have no free
with no free speech guns are banned
instantly
true because what will happen is anybody
who dares speak up and explains why the
second amendment is so important they'll
get banned
then within a few years people are like
why do we have guns anymore do you
that's
all of them it's already happening right
now what's already happening or you'll
have like marauding bands of warlords
that
give no crap about who says what and
they just take control all pure military
yeah and that that's that's a fire that
burns itself out really fast
it's interesting it doesn't it you can't
like you can uh
listen to jordan peterson talk about
chimpanzees like if you're too brutal
it takes two chimpanzees to take out one
brutal
alpha so like the super chimp yeah super
trip right you don't last
no no no but when we're talking about
this information it's easy it's
it's it's on the nose and it's perfect
timing if you do not if
what happens when you have somebody like
um uh who's the
kid from uh david hogg david hogg right
david hogg who overtly says something
like i wear a mask
so people don't think i'm a conservative
now he's the one
making the motion is he's the poster boy
saying oh no that's misinformation
david hogg who's uh like if you listen
to him talk about firearms he doesn't
know what he's talking about
and of course of course and i don't mean
like i don't mean to i'm not gonna punch
down
right like in in some sense the matter
punched down that dude's got a million
followers and he's like
he's he's high-profile well-funded yeah
and isn't he in harvard now
oh yeah like good for him like yeah but
like at the end of the day i
i mean if you listen to david hogg
you don't know anything about what
you're talking about and it's a tough
thing to do
but i don't want him telling me what i
know
you know well this is actually an
interesting uh
kind of like combined conversation we're
talking about 1a and 2a
and i got i got sweet from vosh okay
zovash is a
he's a socialist he's a leftist we've
had him on the show he responded to this
story
about jen saki saying this seems pretty
aft he said companies have a right to
create and enforce tos and the
government has a right to legislate but
the idea
of the government informally pressuring
tech companies into changing their tos
that legislation seems pretty scary
i'm not sure the solution to the mass
spreading of disinformation is but some
solutions certainly seem more 1984 than
others
and then he made a joke all my political
opinions are formed by feeding tweets
into an algorithm which rates them on a
scale of 1776 to 1984.
until i have a stronger opinion on this
my official position is that we can fix
social media disinformation by simply
banning everyone i don't like
now what's funny is he has a follow-up
tweet completely unrelated
of his smith wesson 22 victory which uh
he says came back after sending it off
for repairs
looking very handsome in its new grip in
my honest opinion and i'm just like all
right if we can agree that that was bad
and we can agree that the guns are good
all right we agree we agree yeah i
wonder i i ultimately wonder when we
talk about
the potential for civil war collapse or
balkanization if there really will
be a major conflict if the major
conflict will be the left populous
versus the right populist because i kind
of don't think it will be
i think it'll be more establishment
machine industrialist
yeah we were talking earlier mean forest
in the kitchen downstairs and i was i
think it's going to be economic
rather than military i mean there might
be a military behind the economic but i
think it'll be like a shattering into
state currency or something and then
florida will be like we're not accepting
arkansas coin if you
act like this and the fed's like you
have to accept arkansas coin and they're
like no
no but i think um i think the populists
might end up avoiding each other
to a certain degree the problem though
is a lot of the people on the left
who are actually particularly
authoritarian but i don't think that
they're populist
i think there are left populists there
are many of them unfortunately they give
too much power to the democratic
establishment
but i think if things actually reach you
know if if if it hits the fan
i think most people who are populist or
libertarian-leaning are going to be like
i'm going to sit at my house and grow
vegetables leave me the f alone
so the authoritarians are going to be
cracking down and trying to go after
people can you real quick to find
popular
populism it's when you are uh supported
by and working for the interests of the
population of the people
popular support then you have elitism
which is when you're working for and
supported by the powers of the elites
and then you have the establishment
which is mostly the the elite
infrastructure
the machines the old money the
traditional
um power structures so trump is a
populist
he has almost no support from the elites
tucker carlson is an elite
gives him some support so there's some
people there for sure but he has almost
no elite support but he has tons of
popular support
the elites can muster up a strong force
against that and restrict
access to institutions so all the
institutions are all for the most part
elitist
yeah so the left populists they were the
bernie sanders crowd but then bernie
went totally establishment
then they started voting in people like
biden because i don't think they
understood what they were doing
and interestingly the right populist
movement is actually
not even completely economically or
culturally right-wing
but it's just older left-wing people
like you know like i used to be or
you probably were at some point or still
definitely was yeah more leftist and now
it's kind of like hey
freedom is important and what the
establishment is doing is wrong then you
have these younger left populists
who just the establishment is better
because trump is a fascist
i don't know better authoritarian
populist where they're like we're gonna
legislate for everyone to make it better
for everyone and then they end up
ruining it for a bunch of people on
accident
i think this is a really good place to
put a line of demarcation or
differentiation between two concepts
because
when you're talking about populism we
describe somebody as a populist i don't
prescribe them as a populist
i describe donald trump as a populist
because he gets his support from
people a a person doesn't become a
populist in the sense of
it's a thing that they become it's a
method of description
right and so it whereas in the same
thing in that elitist thing is like well
you could also say that some people are
just they prefer to work for the good of
the elites
so i think populism growing is different
than democracy in the sense it's not a
system of governance but the issue with
populism versus
authoritarianism where we're starting to
see this kind of
tear itself apart is the
authoritarianism
is a top-down approach whereas the
populism is a bottom-up approach
from uh of cultural norms yes right so
they so uh gen saki overtly states
we are an authoritarian we have an
authoritarian view on
cultural norms we have the right as the
elites to dictate to you what is okay
and not okay
whereas donald trump in that if he's
being described as a populist
um is in more of a symbiotic
relationship
of saying i unders you have the values
are coming from the people and they put
their
position into donald trump i will say
when it comes to this tweet from vosh
about the smith wesson 22 victory is uh
my biggest
criticism is that he chose the victory
because i have one
and it and it and it fails to eject the
the case like it just keeps jamming
and so i went online and they were like
you got to like file down the was it
called the ejector pin or whatever
yeah it might be the ejector yeah and so
i'm like you know you shoot a couple
times against jammed
vosh man there's there's better 22s i'm
just kidding that's actually a great gun
it's great yeah i mean and also 22
especially 22 handguns are notorious for
being picky with ammunition right right
right
i was kidding i was kidding voice your
gun looks pretty cool but we do need
more tim and vos drama
yeah we do well well we're we're the
plan right now is charlie kirk and bosh
on august 3rd cool thing i like about
vosh and his name's ian i want to call
ian what's up dude
is he's like really smart like it's
whatever your political beliefs are and
this is kind of what i
always want to remind myself and other
people about it doesn't really matter
what your political beliefs are if
you're really smart and open-minded and
you want to and you like listening to
people
go for it you have to have your
discussion and your ideas you don't got
it you don't got to like the guy you got
to beat him in a debate
of course so for for anybody who's
saying they think he's dumb or they
don't like him it's like yeah
it's definitely not then if you know it
if you know it you can meet him in
debate there you go
that's what it's all about uh anybody
who's willing to come in here and sit
down and have that debate
is that that's great i respect that
because there's there's a lot of people
who are grifting
who outright refuse to come in there
they're even people who are not even
like they're people who are moderately
right who are scared of talking about
certain things
so somebody wants to come and sit in the
lines then and have that i mean look
he's agreed to sit here with charlie and
me charlie
me and charlie don't agree on everything
but we definitely don't agree with vosh
so he's like willing to sit down
on what's what's effectively a two
against one debate
all right that's he's great about
debating i like that about him yeah
i think we're seeing a shift in the way
that we talk about things like
especially like intelligence
is that there's a difference between
being intelligent and being an honest
intellectual
so somebody likes again you could take
somebody who has
the hardware and reward the
practice and they're they understand
something very thoroughly and they're
very very well
versed in a subject but when they come
to a conversation they're not interested
in understanding the subject or coming
to solutions on problems they're
interested in something else
and i think that's a big i think that's
actually a very large undergirding issue
with the way that we address things in
society
i'm not super worried about leftist
youtubers to be completely honest
when we're talking about what's going on
with gensake and the federal government
i i understand that when it came to the
2020 election they played a huge role
in helping the fascistic establishment
machine
take power and that sucks but
that's happened we have the audits
happening we'll see if what more comes
from that we'll see where we end up
but regardless of any of it it seems
like
we're heading towards some kind of
breakup peaceful divorce
decentralization at the very least the
federal government's become too powerful
and now it's starting to lose a lot of
that power like one of the things we
mentioned the other day we mentioned
quite often
the democrats use the federal government
to enact
local laws for everybody in areas that
aren't local to them
and i think a lot of people do this too
it's funny when you see someone running
for congress and they'll be like if you
vote for me
i'll make you know i'll make this place
better it's like
i'm from saint paul minneapolis and i
want to make st
paul clean so vote for me and it's like
bro you represent us to the feds
you go you go you go to dc you're not
here to discuss budget for the local
cleaning of these streets
so what happens is they go to dc and
they say our streets are dirty i demand
we create a massive federal budget to
clean up streets
and then you got some guy who lives in
the mountains of like wyoming and
over in the rockies and he's like what
why why are my tax dollars going towards
it that makes literally no sense
but guns are a better example perfect
somebody somebody in new york being like
these guns are a problem we should ban
them
and there's a guy fighting a grizzly
bear and he hears like you know often on
his radio
they want to ban guns he's like i'm in
the middle of fighting a grizzly bear
i need my gun to fight that grizzly bear
you know there's
uh water collections another interesting
one because in some some states and i
don't have a list of which ones but it's
illegal to collect rain water
i think because it it grows bacteria
like standing water can
in mosquitoes so you don't want it in a
city in some areas of rural america you
you need
you know it's because it's terrain it's
because of groundwater so the pla
typically the places that ban water
collection is because
it would eventually deplete groundwater
reserves the water has to cycle into the
soil and everything like that
that way in colorado it's it's not about
one person having water it's about if
everyone was doing it but then there's
some places that don't do it
imagine if some guy you know like
imagine if arizona went to the federal
government and said we want to pass a
bill that says the great lakes should
share their water with everybody
well not everybody needs the great lakes
water and the great lakes needs it more
than you do
but they need water so they want to pass
laws that affect everybody
so my so now that we're we're past 2020
i i what am i supposed to do am i
supposed to go to a lot of these like
left youtuber types who are like please
vote for joe biden and be
like here's a big list of everything you
screwed up i think a lot of people
realize how bad things are how they got
duped
the promises that were made by the
democrats didn't come true and now you
have all these
you know biden voters posting their ls
on twitter and now i'm just like okay
i'm honestly not worried about
the useful idiots i got burned by george
bush when he told us their weapons of
mass destruction i think everyone needs
to get burned once
by a politician by president and to
realize that that system is
susceptible to corruption it's tough
dude because you know it is
it's that we trust and so when you're
young and you you
you're you know in your 20s and then
obama comes around and he's like
i'm going to bring change and hope get
our troops out of the middle east
it's going to be great and then you're
like this fantastic then the war on
drugs and you're like wow this is it
that's what i've been waiting for i grew
up with these bad guys here's a good guy
and then you get burned and you're like
wow he was a bad guy
screw everybody young people they they
give the benefit of the doubt
they don't do it again sometimes people
do but i think most of the establishment
people
on social media man they are absolutely
just
looking for some kind of personal gain
from the win what do you mean
establishment people
like the the media people the overstate
the cathedral
they're absolutely going to lie cheat
and steal because they're going to be
empowered
you know you said it you said it a
couple times earlier this week and i
think you made the point very clear uh
when joe biden is talking he's not
talking to you
that's what he's meaning he's talking to
his elites he's like yeah
we're doing these things for our own
good your opinion on the matter is
irrelevant
you you as a person ian like or my
i you know when when you when you
present the world in that kind of way
he's not interested in what you think
and so when you even look at
balkanization and decentralization
they're the same thing but one of them
balkanization is more of a
a breaking of political structures as
opposed to
uh decentralization starts in the home
how so so you you know like you have you
have your
experience where you get burned by a
politician
you might become cynical if nothing else
or at least suspicious of all
all of your political of anything
political but that itself is not
self-sufficiency
that itself is just skepticism and
skepticism does not
skepticism manifests into nihilism and
then you just go crazy
so we don't want that so it what you get
this balkanization
this structure that we're talking about
is when i'm
voting for somebody for the house of
representatives
i know that they're going to the house
of representatives representatives of
the feds
so i'm interested in their represent
representation of my state
to the federal government i'm not
interested in their representation to my
state
to its own people because i am sending
them as a representative to the federal
government
and so i focus a lot more on local
politics
right if i live in brooklyn center i am
interested in who is the city council
of brooklyn center if you look at a lot
of the strife that's gone through
minneapolis in the last
year it's all on the local level and
then people on the federal level
like maxine waters come in and cause
more but they don't create it themselves
they
add on to the chaos of the city so when
you look at
like decentralization you could say why
is it that or here's two really good
examples referring to guns um
joe biden's uh not joe biden himself but
like the atf currently put out new
letters redefining
theoretically redefining what a brace is
making these guns sbrs and it's a whole
big
legal problem it effectively will make
anywhere between 10 and 30 million
people felons overnight
uh so yeah if you know if you if you uh
with confiscations all kind of trouble
right so
you have that issue and then texas goes
we as a state
will not allow the federal government to
enforce this law they are
decentralizing their understanding of
firearms rights
from the federal government they're not
getting it from the top down california
did the same thing you're not allowed to
own these guns in our city or in our
state
two very good examples of the opposite
ends of the scale
of both people being decentralized the
states
ultimately com compromise the united
states so
what did you say s b something uh sb
tactical the
no no you said um they were trying to
make stocks illegal to make it an sb
sbr short braille rifle i apologize for
that thank you
yeah if you want to if you want to look
into like the history of terrible laws
look at the nfa
oh yeah the national firearms act
because if your barrel is too short now
you're a bad person yep
why is that because it's easier to
conceal there's there's a
functionally in our current life that
where we live now it is completely
arbitrary and it's because of the
bureaucratic bloat laws never go away
they always get added too
there's there's a forward grip i don't
know what's called but it's like slight
angle
and i was told that if you hold it
improperly it turns your
your pistol into a rifle wow if you put
a
four the atf has determined that if you
put a fore grip
a vertical foregrip on the front of your
on
on a large frame pistol that has a brace
it is considered turning it into an sbr
but there's there's there's a one grip
that's actually like a
it's like a wedge right what i'm talking
about yeah the magpul angled foregrip
i was told that if you hold it the way
it's supposed to be hold it you're fine
but then if you hold it like
oh you're supposed to have your hand in
front of it or behind it and if you put
your hand on it it makes it a foregrip
and now it's
yeah i i do not know the answer to that
one because that is another really
really good point on why this whole nfa
national firearms act
is so problematic is because one it was
it was a gun confiscation scheme that
started a long time ago that failed it
basically failed in the senate or in the
legislation
um and then so that is just again we're
going to make
we want to take all the guns away okay
no it's compromise okay we'll only make
these illegal that's one problem and
then
after that well firearms technology has
changed
massively since that 3d printing it
can't keep up with it
the the legislation cannot keep up with
it and the change in how firearms are
used and how people are used doing uh
they're shooting different types of
competitions they're looking for
different types of firearms for home
defense
they're not just it's not all your
granddad's bolt action anymore are they
gonna are they gonna make um
um rail guns they have them
they're they already exist they're just
not very i mean like nfa items are they
gonna make rail guns banned are they
gonna
you know let's not give the enemy no
idea
we got we got let's loop back because we
are talking about uh you know free
speech and stuff and gensake and there
was another subject i
really want to get into and that's the
freedom phone have you guys heard about
the freedom phone i have i tweeted it
out a couple days ago
all right so freedom phone comes from
this guy who's actually he was actually
hanging out here once when we had
alan bakari on and uh he was showing us
the device and everything and i was like
yeah cool whatever
and it's a phone that he says
will keep your privacy you won't be
tracked it's an uncensorable
uh app store so the apps are gonna be
allowed to be in it and
uh it comes pre-loaded with a bunch of
you know free speech websites and things
like that
let me just say i have not done a
technical review of the product
but boy is this guy over target
seriously
the amount of smear pieces that have
come out about the freedom phone that
are laughably
bad and nonsensical and make no points
is insane i haven't seen any of them
okay so first first the
the the uh the daily beast put out
quite possibly the stupidest smear piece
i've ever seen where they're
like it turns out that freedom phone its
base hardware is actually a chinese
company's phone
and then i see people on twitter being
like whoa really and i'm like i don't
understand what that means
so what did you think the guy built the
phone from scratch
in a factory in scranton or something of
course he outsourced the base phone
what do people think this is but that's
the narrative trying to weave it's a bad
phone you can't have it because
it was made in china i'm like yeah along
with like every other phone i guess
so you you probably still want to do
some kind of forensic analysis on it to
see if there's data leak or whatever to
see if it's actually doing what he
claims to
take us out the daily news right wing
activist
push 500 freedom phone made in china and
seemingly available under a less
patriotic name for 120
this is a lie this headline is a lie for
one simple reason
let me explain to you what the headline
actually says let's say i have a canvas
that costs five dollars and i paint a
picture of ian on it
and then i say hundred dollars and they
come with a headline
the canvas that tim is selling for a
hundred dollars actually can be bought
at hobby lobby for five oh my
yeah but i painted a picture on it so
this has got a
it's got apps it's got proprietary
operating system some people don't know
how to load those things
so if you want those things you pay for
them but wait there's more it gets even
better oh good
we have this story from gizmodo maga
branded freedom phone is a black box
that should be avoided at all costs
nobody can blame gop voters for wanting
a phone that prioritizes privacy and
autonomy but the freedom phone can't be
trusted why
they don't actually give a good reason
why it can't be trusted they just say
it's a chinese phone okay so do it do a
hard wipe on it or don't trust him
why would i trust apple or google over
some random guy sorry i trust random guy
over these major companies
but wait there's more cnet uncensorable
freedom phone raises a host of security
questions
no it doesn't they're freaking out over
this
good freedom phone and again i have not
vetted the device
i have not done any technical review on
it i look forward to
so i hear about this phone and i'm like
oh that'll be interesting i should i
should hit on my buddies and we should
we should gut it and we should like
really go through it and see what he's
got going on in it
but to see all of these people so what
happened was i saw
robbie suave a libertarian guy from
reason
tweeted uh in response i think to
candace owens or something that was a
griff that they're grifting selling this
phone
and i'm like why why why is it a grip i
don't understand jack murphy responded
with
is there a reasonable critique of this
because i've not you know that you've
written about
ian miles chong then responds that it's
just a chinese phone
you know daily beast wrote about it my
response is like oh the great
tech technologists and intrepid
reporters of the daily beast and their
expertise on the far far far far far
right
they know exactly how a phone works
there are people who are just
freaking out over the idea that you
could have
an a phone pre-built to keep you off
their grid
big tech must be sweating all of a
sudden all these are
like bro i googled this story earlier
today and i saw a bunch of articles i
just googled it now to pull this up
way more articles and they're saying
things like the phone
one person tweeted a hacker the phone
the data set that the chipset could be
hacked if they have physical access to
the device
and i'm like that's good you don't want
access to your own device no no no no
they're saying someone else can hack
your phone
if they have physical access and i'm
like that's true for my refrigerator
dude right
it's true for my car if someone gets
physical access
to my device they can do a lot of things
with it
it is insane how how much they're
freaking out over this um
i he was saying that they scoured the
united states to try and build it here
and
the they found out that the united
states is not capable of producing
phones
i will say one of the funniest things
was though eric finn man who made this
tweeted out the video like here's the
thing then he tweeted
what you said we scoured the us to find
a factory that could build these phones
the
unfortunate reality is that there's
nothing there's no factories that could
build at scale
and it says twitter for iphone
underneath it that's awesome he tweeted
out
he's using the iphone you know you got
to do research that's i use
youtube facebook twitter i built mines
but well i didn't build it i was there
come on
using his own phone yeah probably yeah i
wonder if it doesn't
i wonder if that was on twitter he put
that out i wonder if tweeted with an
iphone if he doesn't use twitter from
the freedom phone i wonder how that
i can't wait to talk to this guy yeah
yeah it should be interesting but
there's something to be said about what
we're hearing from the federal
government jenseki
censoring people shutting them down
banning them from every platform then a
dude comes out and he's like this device
has all these pre-loaded apps it's super
easy for you
you want to know why this is so powerful
and so important because it can be
replicated
very very quickly and easily and regular
people who have no technical expertise
are being provided with a service
that very simply could potentially grant
them
privacy security eliminate the tracking
and stop the censorship
not to mention unit freedom phone really
needed to include i don't know if they
do mesh networking capabilities
that's right so again i want to see one
of these devices
and i used to do a ton of hacking i made
i was i was saying this earlier i made a
i once hacked an android to be a pit boy
from fallout 3. nice it's not hard to do
it's just literally hard you get skins
you get a new os you put it on you do it
and then
you get the little pit boy thing and uh
then you get the app where the light
it puts the light into your skin to
track your like pulse and everything and
then you actually have like the fall
three thing anyway
i'd love to gut this thing see what's
going on but what's what's powerful
about it
i am not sponsored by this company i do
not have one of these phones there is no
promo code for me
i in no way i'm saying that it's a it's
the best one ever
the idea that somebody could make
privacy as a service or as a product as
hardware
scares them the beast the machine the
overstate the cathedral yeah
similar to those 3d printed uh ghost
guns when they just came out
man they did not like that they still
don't yeah you can't yeah the the
the motto behind that is you can't stop
the signal i mean the they're already
out there
it's too easy to make now we need we
need to figure out how to make something
like this
as easily replicable as like you know 3d
printing
yeah okay i mean at one point in time
i'm sure we'll be able to achieve that
and the other interesting thing that
your articles include is they all sound
like they're
targeting potential right-wing consumers
yeah who are reading gizmodo on the
daily basis
this is that's probably the closest i
can get to conspiracy
thought on that one but it definitely
sounds like they're not really
interested in
normal gizmodo readers right very
interesting
they're very interested in oh those
people are going to search for
freedom phone and we want to discourage
people who are interested in the free
which we want to
so the you know like right-wing
extremism and the term they use are the
things that
people who are on the right don't like
being called
you want to know you want to know why i
lean on i see these stories they've
provided no evidence of anything
they're saying it could potentially be
hacked if someone has physical access
and i'm like okay well then don't lose
your phone like don't get your phone
stolen
okay add security apps to it i suppose
the chips that could be hacked
or whatever the reason why i think this
is more most likely on the level
is that you cannot put out a phone and
then allow communities to hack it
and not find what you're doing so
basically if
google and apple put out phones and
regular people break into them
and oh no they've hacked it they've got
physical access people jailbreak phones
all the time
and then they find out where the
tracking is coming from what data is
being leaked and where
of course they'll be able to do it with
fun which is made by some guy
some guy's phone but he says they've
they've taken little bits from a bunch
of different operating systems to create
their own operating system one of which
is called graphene os
and i hear a lot of people saying
there's no reason to buy the phone just
buy your own foot and put graphene os on
it and i'm like
yeah that's actually great if you know
how to do it
but see what's scaring them is that 45
year old mildred
can be like i don't know nothing about
that phone booting but i'll buy one of
those freedom phones like no no no we
need to spy on you
yeah oh what's mine it comes pre-loaded
with mines yeah i do
make an account on mines what i'm not
getting tracked yep
that's right or maybe you're not getting
trash i still like you said i haven't
yeah so it's it's you know you get a ton
of people on the right they're promoting
it they're giving their promo codes for
it
and the establishment is like like
what's the target baby you said that you
can't stop the signal
that must go in many directions like
does that also mean that
you can't stop your signal from being
tracked regardless of what
your signal is and where it is oh it's a
reference to the it's referencing to 3d
printing guns like the technology is so
simple now
that you can do it and it's not hard to
do they're just making it illegal
but it the i mean you know if you know a
modicum
about the internet you know that they
can't block things you get the what was
the uh the
effect that it would like don't take a
picture of my house and start a sand
effect right
and that's exactly what's happening like
people it is one of our most read
articles is like where to find 3d
printed gun files
it's on the internet right and and like
we uh another interesting thing about
that too is like we're
we have we currently have a pre-order
for a hard pa
or paper copy of a bunch of diy things
like how to build guns and how to do all
these kind of how to
diy your own suppressor all of it is
legal all of it is exactly like hey this
is what you do do not do this because
you this is again this is breaking the
law
but it's like okay now i have the book
there and that helps and then it's it's
it's that digitally back during
prohibition they used to sell
it was a powdered powdered wine
and it would you'd buy it and it would
come with a car that said warning
do not pour this into a bottle and then
store it in a cabinet
for one month because it will turn into
wine and wine is illegal
don't do that so people work
it was like it was like grape juice or
whatever like you powdered grape juice
and it was like don't put this in the
it'll turn into wine yeah don't people
had wine don't look at
that guy everyone's like what guy
streisand yeah for sure
streisand effect you know what man uh i
i don't know it's gonna be interesting
to see what this this phone's capable of
but uh regardless of that i think people
would be
would be well suited to actually learn
about android devices
and custom operating systems and
security features and things like that
because uh these are spying on you and
if you think they're not you are wrong
do you think they have satellites that
can
listen in to us right now with like long
range radio waves
uh no these lasers lidar what is it
i think you're overthinking it they're
just listening to the stream yeah
that's for sure true i've opted in yeah
well i mean you've got devices
everywhere if they really wanted to
listen to this oh bro we got the
amazon robot over there yeah yeah but
then like if you're out in the woods and
you don't have any sell signal can they
listen to you well that is a question
that i cannot answer
alexa are you spying on us
she just basically is like we take
privacy very seriously look at the app
and
you know she didn't answer your question
yes that was a non-denial denial
yep thanks amazon we're being spot-on
i did thank that computer earlier today
i think i'm either going insane or
evolving to the robot yeah you know it'd
be cool if like
you know we're not there's there's no
overstate there's no cathedral it's just
someone invented an ai like 10 years ago
and it took over
and now we're like trapped in the
machine you know so you're actually
fighting the ai and you'll never win
yeah that's encouraging so life's a
video game
i mean i'm not saying that but maybe
like it's a self-propelling organism
and we're just kind of kind of no i'm
sorry it's like a car the faster a car
moves
the less you have to turn the wheel to
make it go crazy in a different
direction i'm just saying what if like
dr johnson 10 years ago like i've done
it i've created ai
and then the ai was like hello dr
johnson and then after 10 years he like
controlled the like it's like a movie
you know what i mean that one with
johnny depp where he like puts his brain
in the machine and takes over or
whatever
the ai would have been like i have
created dr johnson yeah there you go
it's like ultron you know what if you
created an ai but then the ai
thought it has always been here never
mind i don't want to derail the
conversation into this
well it's actually the singularity yeah
it isn't
i'm pretty sure the singularity is when
the ai becomes self-conscious and and
and replicatable at a point where it
can't be solved yeah and i'm pretty sure
we're not there yet i don't think no or
not but according to lex friedman
one of the pioneers and leading ai
scientists on earth
that is inevitable like that is what
that ai is going to become
self-replicable and will create itself
and proliferate unstoppably
and anybody who's watched stargate knows
that the replicators go to war with the
asgard and then
right it's a tough war man over oh
really you know what do you guys know
what grey goo
is the grey goo apoc apocalyptic
scenario no
it's a reference to humans or you know
creating a nanobot which self-replicates
and then it keeps eating materials to
create more and more of itself
and then eventually it's consumed all
matter on the planet all that's left is
what appears to be a gray goo
but when you zoom in it's a bunch of
tiny nanobots all just
yeah you want i highly recommend
paperclip simulator if you want to play
a game like that where you just make
paper an ai that makes paperclips
oh and it destroys the world turns
everything in the paper clips and then
it creates
drones that go out into space to make
more drones to make more paperwork
that's
it keeps going and changing and like
going to the next level and the next
it's crazy it's like a video game it's
just like um a browser game that's all
like numbers and data and like you watch
the numbers going up and up and up
oh i see i see it's really good it's not
like an actual game that'd be awesome to
make
i guess technically it's a game yeah
check it out but like a 3d game where no
not yet
consume the planet maybe wild like
explore
didn't somebody create a game where you
like you basically create a plague
that's supposed to take out the planet
oh yeah
and then after after covet began they
they what did they do they stopped
selling china trying to ban the sale of
it and then they
they made a um an expansion called the
cure
now so let's play against the cure and
now you played and trying to kill the
virus
oh now you're trying to cure the virus
yes yeah interesting it's a little and
and before anybody makes
you know makes aware of it i am aware
that i say the word plague wrong
plague clay
so uh uh talking about you know we got
the freedom phone stuff we got people
resisting we've got
now the populist left and the right are
like yo jen sack you're crossing the
line you're
losing it for the longest time i was
saying
um you know civil war of some sort
but that was because we were looking at
it through the lens of last the last
election cycle where the populist left
was very much aligned with the
establishment
now that joe biden's in i was saying
it's the biggest mistake for them to
bring joe biden in because
this will fracture them from the
populist left yeah they should have used
bernie
s somebody who yeah and bernie was
playing ball they would have twisted him
man
oh they did twist him but anyway the
point is now with bidenin
conservatives hate biden disaffected
liberals politically homeless ifw hate
biden and the populist left hates biden
they have put into office a man
everybody hates now to be fair he's not
the most hateable guy because of how
pathetic and old and befuddled he is
but no one likes him yeah so now it kind
of feels like
that's taken away the prospect of an
actual faction versus faction clash
and opened up what appears to be
balkanization so
i want to show you guys this because we
talked about it yesterday this is the
chart that we pulled up last time
support for seceding from the us to form
a new regional union
the pacific region is 39 the mountain
region is 32 the heartland is 30 the
northeast is 34 and the south is 44. so
what i did
was and this is yougov data i added up
all the numbers divided them by five
and got you know 35 or so percent it's
an incorrect number because
the pacific region has about 53 million
people and the southern region has 107
million people
so 44 of 107 million is substantially
more than 30
39 of 53 million i did all the math the
full number is
37.2 million people so i added up the
total populations
then i took the percent 44 of 107. i
added them together
divided them by the the actual
population 37.2 percent of
this country is in favor of their region
splitting off from the country
tell me why it's a bad idea well firstly
we're getting a poll that's
only only pulled like 3 000 people i
think right 2 800 people total
which is apparently like twice what you
need for a representative sample
technically but it's
it's only like point one what is that
point zero one percent of the population
got pulled on this
so i i i could see you know random
errors hold on hold on so
what you're basically saying is that
they got lucky
in that everyone they asked just
happened to be the people who wanted to
secede could have been no
it could have been the way they were
asking the question to like do you want
to secede from the union they're like
well i never thought of that
the question the question was something
like would you support
your region breaking off from the united
states to form a new regional yeah and
if someone had never thought that before
and then they saw that question they
might be like
yeah sure yeah okay so they support it
like it wasn't like they were like
i want this to happen and they thought
of it on their own like they're being
coaxed into answering
i i think you're attacking the poll
which is
it's yougov data yougov is pretty pretty
good and it's 2750 people which is
more than needed for a representative
sample it is i'm not i'm not trying to
say the polls perfect those polls are
pretty trash
yeah if it was 70 million people that
voted for something like this i'd be
now this would be hot hot hot to me like
tim said
polls are typically garbage um but if
you want to ask someone a question and
kind of figure out what people are
really thinking you could break it down
with any question you could be like this
poll is wrong because they asked it in
this way
so i feel like you're kind of splitting
hairs i don't care i don't care about
arguing about whether polls are good or
not
talking about based on this data 37.2
percent of people want to balkanize the
united states
is that a good or bad thing if you want
to ask me why would
i consider it a bad idea which is not
the opinion that i'm going to espouse is
because we've never done it successfully
without mass conflict but you think it's
a good idea
i think that it's something that we're
exploring that could very well be a good
idea i mean it it
it's an it's it's we're in the
exploratory stage it's certainly the
better
it's a better option than many many
things
i would much rather have peaceful
divorce than than
um what happened in bosnia right right
you know like
i would rather have peaceful divorce
than the constant riots in minneapolis
being the
new normal that's fair um i would rather
have
some form of ability for american the
current country that is america where
people go okay
you know what then we're gonna we're
gonna finally have the motivation to
move here and we're going to
build our families and we're going to
build our cultures and we're going to
realize that this ship will never meet
again like this we
we have to stand at odds or you know
maybe
there's you could you could take it more
cynical ways but
yeah i would much rather have it than
some sort of authoritarian dictatorship
where it's like i'm under the boot
of you know somebody he doesn't it
pick an authoritarian that's that even
holds
all of my views i don't you know you you
mentioned something i had said
earlier in that biden isn't talking to
you when
just seriously when genseki comes out
when biden comes out
everybody listening to the show knows
biden is not talking to them because he
says things that are not in line with
literally what their states are doing or
what their representatives want
or the people have voted for so the
example easily being when biden said we
need more lockdowns
and taxes in florida had literally
reopened everything to the support
of their of of the residents and the
citizens of their of their states
so biden is literally saying our
democracy and our country
and they're they're actually saying the
republicans are the problem in fact let
me let me pull up this uh
this story from newsweek gosh ex trump
official
says gop greater national security
threat to u.s
than isis or al-qaeda the grand old
party
the republicans so when joe biden comes
out and says
what the republicans are doing is the
biggest threat since the civil war
you know he is already saying this
country
is not unified and they are the enemy
well it also it also goes back to your
point is he saying that
and this is where you have to make a
really important parsing is he saying
that
the republicans are the biggest threat
to the country or to his
regime and i think the answer is b
no i think he's saying country and i
think he views the country
as only his supporters and only his
states right exactly say we're splitting
hairs in the conversation i agree with
you yeah
so what does that mean for the rest of
us i suppose i kind of think we're
already
balkanized the way we built this country
was absolutely incredible we have these
states
with this massive power these state
powers so that's kind of what the
balkans are as a bunch of states
um so as long as we reign the power of
the federal government
i think that we're already ready to go
man we're bo we're balkanized and ready
man
we're a a decentralized union of states
go ahead um i was gonna say i think that
if you look at the example of the
balkans that's not good that's not
encouraging
uh we could probably look at something
like the eu and if we go into it in an
organized fashion which i don't think we
are i think that everything's going to
be
insanely slip shot like the voting in
2020 give me a freaking break
absolute insanity i think that we're
more likely to be more like the balkans
than the eu
but if we could do something like the
european union that would be you know
from talking to a british dude about the
eu he was saying it was really horrible
because
it was like unelected leadership would
make decisions for
england all of a sudden that's exactly
what i've been saying about the
democrats
yep dude i move out to the middle of
nowhere
because i don't want to live in philly
when i live in philly you know i live in
we live in the suburbs and i hear like
they want to pass certain laws i'm like
i get it that makes sense because i live
in a city i live in an urban area
moved to middle of nowhere now all of a
sudden i'm hearing what the democrats
are doing and i'm like that makes
literally no sense because now i
understand what it's like to be in the
middle of nowhere
the one thing i realized is how come i
wasn't hearing the inverse
how come i wasn't living in the city
hearing policies about why we need to
legalize raising livestock in our homes
because republicans don't fight for
things so
if you live in an urban environment and
you hear the debate in washington
you're probably thinking like this
debate makes sense the republicans are
insane for denying this
if you move to a rural area you hear the
debate and you're like why aren't the
republicans fighting for what we need
where we live
i think a lot of these young leftists
grow up in cities they don't understand
that i mean
we can't already have it we have it
that's why they're not trying to change
it like you were saying laws get made
but they don't get
they don't get broken apart yeah they
don't get enough maybe they should have
sunset clauses built in
yes there's a there's like there are
books called like you know bat
like ridiculous laws or whatever there's
like some law where you can't take
showers on tuesdays and like
massachusetts or something like that
some some town
there's laws where it's like you can't
put an apple pie in your windowsill on
sunday afternoons yeah
and these laws made sense at the time
but they were passed when there were
like 300 people living in the city and
now there's 500 000
so it's like not being able to shower on
tuesdays was because
they had you know a certain amount of
water or like you know
the city was you know limited in some
capacity
you can't have you know pies on your
window sill on sunday because
something was happening the church
you know just they had reasons for this
stuff they don't make sense anymore
so the so the term balkanization i mean
it's still kind of a newer concept for
us right and so we're i mean not it's
it's newer in the cultural conversation
for sure
um you know it's at least since the
civil war i guess
that would be a good way of saying it
but so perhaps when we're talking about
balkanization we're also thinking about
it in the same way that we tend to
address like
hyper aggressive authoritarianism
they're really like
very very far out concepts like for us
we could move towards balkanization by
moving towards decentralization
and not actually have to reach full-out
balkanization
but and that would be something that you
do in degrees you don't just go okay
cool we're breaking apart here's the
lines we're done
but that requires certain things of
people to do uh as
citizens like you know agree that we
shouldn't elect people that threaten
their own
population with violence or we you know
whatever like that you could do that
i i think the issue you know one of the
things they brought up in the study was
most people are actually just saying
they want power so
66 percent of republicans in the south
want to secede
but would they be saying that when trump
was president maybe not
maybe not because they have the power
right now and so therein lies the
problem that joe biden comes out and he
is like
i will crush my enemies and the
establishment dams are going
yes and they're clapping and cheering
for it that i think is the most
dangerous part
is that is that we are now making it
culturally acceptable to
uh overtly express from a position of
power in politics while also feigning
the act of being the victim
that we think it is good to do exactly
to exact violence on our opponents i
think it's a very very specific reason
why we don't do that in public
that's why i was saying i'm more worried
about the establishment than the
populist leftists
yeah there's there's an issue i'm saying
populist i'm not saying
uh antifa authoritarians and black lives
matter those they serve the
establishment
i'm saying like you know the left's
arguments about all the stuff i'm kind
of like yeah whatever dude i live in the
middle of nowhere like
have your hippie commune have your
healthcare whatever let's you know
if this if the states break apart to
regional unions you can go move to the
one that better suits your needs
i would say the biggest problem with it
is china that's what i've long said
that china just takes over the moment
this happens they go thank you taiwan's
theirs
what's the history of the balkans anyway
are you guys familiar with how how did
it shatter what was it before
it balkanized and then uh what was it
after kosovo i know was part of that
serbia i don't know because it used to
be man i'm just i'm not educated enough
on but i've what i got a message from
someone there like i was
in the balkans when the i think it was
the kosovo war and they're like it was
like nazi germany it was worse i think
they actually said it was worse than
nazi germany and i don't think they were
in nazi germany but
it was just like i mean i don't know but
mass mass chaos
it's introduction you know what's really
interesting about this is there's been a
lot of like
legit far right people several years ago
were talking about wanting to balkanize
the us and we all scoffed and laughed at
the idea
now they have a poll coming out where
it's like apparently americans want to
do this i think it's bad in the long run
we don't want china take over i mean we
got problems here
joe biden's a nut the democrats and the
neocons are really really bad the
establishment politicians are really bad
but
look at the show we're allowed to do
that we wouldn't be allowed to do if we
lived in china
oh i know why do you what do you think
about the american russian
like relations i i personally feel like
the united states and russia should be
the most intimate of allies to protect
the earth
yeah i mean i don't know about that two
of the largest land masses on earth
they're not
authoritarian chinese consciousness
russia has more land than pluto
russia's does it really work gigantic
yeah russia is massive but most of it's
a lot of it's siberia but that's still
cool yeah
because if that ice melts away yeah if
it warms up
uh i would love to like preserve the
arctic with like a global let me
let me let me tell you something um i
was in moscow once at the airport
when you board a plane in the united
states the lady goes
now burning group one and you get up and
and
advantage members and global pass or
whatever they call it and then you
everyone in this group when you you're
sitting there on your phone they get up
and they go to board one by one
now boarding group q then group two gets
up
so um i'm in russia at the moscow
airport transferring i was flying
ukraine
and they announced now boarding group
one every single person got up and ran
full speed like literally running with
like rushing
and then shoving each other out of the
way and waving their tickets at the lady
and then the lady would like just grab
one and then beep and the guy would
squeeze his way through him on the plane
it was not boarding by anything it was
just chaos
and i was like this is weird and i
talked to my friend who was ukrainian
about it
and the general conversation was she was
she was saying is
yeah that's normal like that's how it's
like eastern european people do that all
the time and i was like that's so weird
in america we just
like group one boards and you get up and
you sit there and you wait because if
you go up without your ticket they'll
tell you hey you're not group one go sit
down
and then what you basically said was
during the soviet union
the people who survived were the ones
who are going to steal the extra loaf of
bread
who are going to surreptitiously gain
extra food somehow or
cheat on their on their you know books
or whatever or get money or illegally
sell things or smuggle
the people who would do whatever it took
to get what they wanted to survive
and now these people are the children
and some of them lived in the soviet
union so who survived with those hundred
years of soviet communist oppression
the people who were willing to rush to
the front of the line to grab that loaf
of bread before someone else got it
they had kids they grew up and that's
the culture that persisted
now it wasn't the conversation wasn't
that was the general idea of the
conversation and i was like wow dude
so there's problems with russia and many
of the former soviet states in that
the soviet union created you know
survivors
it created countries of people who would
do whatever it took to survive
and with that comes pros and cons so
what is russia
vladimir putin we must take power we
must we must
we must succeed we mustn't give up
former kgb guy the united states is not
like that
now it's kind of being like that because
the idea because
america has been so lacks and so
accepting with all these good times
we let you know wolf fox at the hen
house and now we got the ideologues
taking over the government mark milley
has gone as woke as what can get
that dude's cracked out of his mind mark
milly has lost it
like dude's nuts cultist fully
ideologued
that's scary and so you this the
the the i don't know what you'd call it
but the
pragmatic you know um reasonable mind is
not winning this one
russia does not have it and it's not and
i'm not saying that to be disrespectful
but
the mentality of russia is very much
like vladimir putin
there's rumors that he's the richest man
on the planet because he's you know
controls all this money
he's a he's a permanent political you
know president or whatever in russia
it's just
i don't know about all that man yeah
it's pretty disgusting but
you know you know so is being human in a
lot of ways you gotta poop every day
that's pretty gross
yeah but what i mean to say is it looks
like authoritarianism is on the rise
everywhere
even in the u.s i uh i would say there's
a silver lining to russia's
authoritarianism
because the countries that remember what
communism is like are going to be some
of the last
bastions of western strength i think
like hungary
poland romania estonia romania all of
these little countries they will
never go back to communism and the
further you get i think the further you
get from communism the more likely you
are to repeat it i think that's what
we're seeing in the u.s
yeah yeah i mean if you look into the
you know the marx marxism
is an interesting thing he just thought
it was like that you're talking about
hegelian dialectics and his wiser people
than me that have talked about this
he more or less thought it was
inevitable and you'll also look at
the concept of insurgency which is a
topic that i've been studying more
recently and it's very interesting to
see that insurgency is sort of like it
preys on the natural weaknesses of
liberal democracies
is what it does yes so like so what you
kind of get is
i think of when i think of communism i
think of something like
it's a fever you're gonna get every
century and if you can survive it you
get another hundred years but if you
don't survive it
it takes you know do you see what the
the the democrat what black lives matter
and aoc have said about cuba
yeah that's that's that's some creatures
what is up with the black lives matter
praising castro there is that reason so
hold on yes
absolutely it's real they were saying
rest in power castro mark
millie our general supports that
this dude this is dark stuff and you
know what trump should have fired the
guy
but anyway i mean this is freaky stuff
rude you got aoc and black lives matter
coming out saying
it's not cuba's fault it's not
communism's fault
it's america's fault i love this idea
because it's so social it's so communist
that
if if ian is hungry it's my fault for
not giving him my food
it's like okay i could help him i could
but ian's food is ian's responsibility
not mine were you preventing me from
getting the food
from getting my food yeah so was america
like
sanctioning cuba and embargo down
america wasn't trading with cuba
before castro got into power i think
this was mostly having to do with the
communist revolution
but but regardless does cuba have land
does cuba have fish does america have an
obligation to trade with countries that
are actively working against them
no ian what do you got in that war room
pandemic i don't want to tell you tim
well if you i'm suffering and i want it
no it's mine
stay off my coffee my suffering is the
fault of ian for not giving me his mug
that's propaganda
don't listen to him before that's that's
what they're saying
so america because america is not giving
them stuff
it's our fault they're suffering what is
the cuban right it's not what it's not
just what they're saying it's what they
believe
like no no and that's a bigger problem
because people act on beliefs
bro this is the perfect two-year-old
toddler tantrum mentality
you see that video of the woman falling
on the ground and screaming because she
was being filmed no but i've heard of it
that's that's that perfectly exemplifies
millennials for the most for the most
part
unfortunately not all millennials are
bad we seem to be good people you guys
seem to be good people
but what happens is cuban people are in
revolution saying down with dictatorship
libertad
and then aoc is like america should give
them free stuff
no no no no no aoc you give them your
free stuff yeah there you go
do it yourself don't do it with somebody
else's stuff just do it yourself i just
looked this up it's july 26 1953 was the
beginning of the cuban revolution it
ended january 1st 1959 so about a
six-year revolution
that is after 1946 which is when the
liberal economic order was established
basically the military-industrial
complex that eisenhower told us about
and it's possible that america was
suppressing the hell out of that country
in what way i really don't know it's a
conspiracy at this point like force and
i were talking about conspiracy theories
and the
kind of the problem with them is that
you want to believe something is true
because
it gives you a sense of empowerment to
be like i get it
so there's something good about me that
i understand
so first and foremost i think people
should be responsible for themselves
like yeah i i look i i believe in
charity i like social programs
but people are responsible for
themselves to it to a great degree
if you don't have food i may be a good
person and help you but
if you give a man a fish you feed them
for a day if you teach a man to fish you
feed him for the rest of his life
in the end if i ultimately say bro you
like
there's a homeless guy outside and he's
like let me sleep in your house and i'm
like
no you are causing my suffering it is
your fault
then activists jumping like the only
reason this man is suffering is because
tim pool won't let him in his house it's
like
no the dude is responsible for his own
shelter man to a point but the french
revolut
no literally two periods but if there's
a a monarch that's
that's hoarding all the materials so
that the people are starving and
suffering it is the monarch's fault
why because he's by force keeping them
from their stuff
or what the stuff that they their
community has produced
so can they like leave it depends i mean
is the king behind you you can't even
leave yeah um that actually is a good
question because where are you gonna go
are you gonna go west
right you go in the middle of the woods
oh yeah i mean that works
with us my point is about cuba cuba's
food problem is cuba's problem cuba's
medicine problem is cuba's problem
there is no obligation from any other
country to give to them
yes and it's not america's fault they
don't have stuff and in the cold war
when you side against our enemies we are
not obligated to feed you when your
social experiment fails yeah we have a
cuban missile crisis
it's the same thing with conservatives
it's like you know they're not obligated
to
not conservatives it's like okay let's
let's use a really good example like i
mean
you know a lot of people even rag on
iron rand's argument through uh
atlas shrugged it's like at some point
in time the people providing are gonna
stop doing it and then your arguments
your high high-handed you know moral
arguments on the greatest good for the
greatest number
won't mean a thing that's exactly it
let's say america didn't exist at all oh
no cuba can't trade to get food from
america
because there isn't one to
to be entirely fair american foreign
policy has not always had the highest
end goals in mind
we see that in the middle east i don't
know enough about cuba
and the embargo there i'm just saying
that i don't really trust the us's
like high-handed assertions of what
they're doing anymore
bro these these these commies they
communism comes to being when
entitled people think they are owed
things and then want to take them from
you
i actually disagree with you on that one
you don't think that's where communism
comes from i think communism comes from
your
your the i think
i think communism comes from a base
morality of selfishness i just wanted
that's i i don't think it's entitlement
i think
well i think entitlement is this thing
of like there are
there are things owed to me perhaps
because i exist or because of of
of other things i think i think when
communism is born out of malice
it's i don't like you and i'm better
than you and if i believe this i'm
holier than
you you know i mean authoritarianism
maybe
but that's like what you're the point of
what's the difference between
communism and authoritarianism communism
is communism is literally about the
ownership by the community
meaning you have people who are like i
should that should be mine
so it's the about like marxism the
abolishment of private property right
no it's not owned by the by the commons
by the people it's not the [ __ ]
it never functions it's not the
abolishment of private property it's the
abolishment of your property for my
benefit
yeah yeah yeah but if you look at the
things like if you look what aoc is
saying you look at what the squad is
talking about and things like that
they're basically saying other people
have things that i want and i should
they should be given to me yeah so we
are saying the same thing but i i think
i think it's fundamentally not born out
of like an intellectual deficiency i
think it's
fundamentally born out of a moral
difficult i agree with you yeah yeah
these people have never lifted a heavy
object in their lives communism ends in
mass murder always because it requires
absolute
uh what do you call it um and everyone
needs to do it willingly
if if one objector exists then this the
entire
because we system pull our resources you
get you give all your recent services
you give all of yours lydia gives all of
hers i give all of mine but then i go
wait no i want to keep this
that act alone now the only thing that
you can do is either dissolve the whole
system because it broke or you have to
kill me
it requires well gulag or steal your
stuff well i got really loud there for
you
yeah i mean but why does it why does it
always fail in that same manner it's
because it requires
absolute volunteerism if you have one
person who says no
i don't think so for good reason or evil
it doesn't matter
i don't want to be a part of your
experiment for whatever reason by their
own choice
it it fails at that moment that's why
right libertarianism
right libertarianism is the best if the
united states
elected an actual right libertarian a
dave smith for instance and he was like
i'm going to leave you alone and do your
thing
then the hippies could have their
commune the left libertarians
i think was ron paul who said it's like
in america you can create your own
commune no one's stopping you
it's that these people want your stuff
that's what they're actually doing they
want you to uphold them when their
system fails
there there is there i think there's
more than one successful communes
they have about 100 people and they
don't allow it to go larger than that so
you can apply to join
and then as soon as someone leaves next
in line gets admitted into the commune
everybody has jobs and you all live and
everything's shared
but there are people who own it and run
it so there's still authority who was it
that was saying that all the most
successful communes have been
christian or religious based is that
true i think yesterday's something yeah
yeah somebody's mentioning their own
throughout history yeah then you also
have things like the gnostics but they
kind of died in the desert
look if blood didn't work so well if
everybody believes in the same ideology
then your commune works
yeah because you all you have a you have
a shared sense of belief you can't you
can't have communism and
multiculturalism
right you can't have communism and you
know like it's just it's fundamentally
incompatible with
basically all of humanity well actually
i mean honestly i think that a
functioning country probably needs some
kind of religion
yes how deep do you want to go into the
definition of religion yeah money is it
needs a shared ideology
yeah it needs it needs a share so if a
religion is not so much a belief in like
a supernatural god but rather
a hierarchy of values again a moral
framework a moral frame
so my religion is the what i call a
religion is the hierarchy of values
whatever's at the top of that is my god
so if i am calling myself an atheist i'm
also calling myself god because it is my
mind that determines everything that is
real and so
it's sort of it's sort of it's my mind
that determines what's right and wrong
for some
if i don't use something outside of me
to inform me on what is right and wrong
i am saying my mind is the ultimate
authority on right and wrong at least
within my existence and i don't think
that's a completely
unrespectable position you just need to
be humble and honest and realize that's
what it is
and so yeah a religion is a ordered a
hierarchy of values
and if a culture doesn't have a unified
hierarchy of values
how would it work together right
multi-ideologism doesn't work
i like that word salad though
multi-ideology is a word yeah i like it
so in the u.s having a bunch of
different ideologies doesn't work
no well yeah i mean i know
what does word mean to work you know i
mean it provides opportunity to debate
things that's for sure
true mm-hmm well it doesn't work in the
sense that without social cohesion it
balkanizes
no yeah exactly everyone fights in a way
the us dollar
i think is modern religion i mean bro
look at look at look at the the child
drag shows
like come on like there is a hard line
for for a lot of regular people but the
left
supports the child stripping 100 percent
they defend at every turn probably on
tribal grounds
because they don't actually care because
they have no more like
this is the funniest thing i think a lot
of conservatives need to realize
not just conservatives but like i don't
know what you call that leftist group
okay
because i'm fairly revolutionary in a
lot of respects like i want to change i
think the country needs to change a
whole lot
i'm not like federal reserve get it out
of there you know conservatives who are
like stop we're gonna keep things the
same i'm like you know let's change it
all
but i think i draw the line with the
kids stripping for money at the very
least
and what a lot of people who are in the
culture war right don't understand is
these people don't share your values at
all there's a video of a four-year-old
twerking
and they're all laughing and clapping
and cheering as that happens yeah there
are people in this country that
value stripping you of your your right
to own a firearm as a good thing they
don't think of it as a
means to an end they think of it as a
good thing yeah you shouldn't have a gun
period
yeah it doesn't matter like you you they
they view you as sub-human if it's a
human right to own a firearm and they
say you don't have the right you're
they're
they're viewing you as sub-human the
only reason
it's all about it this way with it with
the child stripping
why aren't uh people like running
like why aren't there armed men shutting
down child stripping and grooming
shows why aren't people in new york
going up and being like stop what you're
doing to this four-year-old child right
now put that camera away and stop this
twerking
in new york they overwhelmingly have the
same moral framework
they like it they celebrate it and the
people
who don't are probably leaving like
could you imagine somebody who is you
know probably like
take somebody who's you know probably
opposed to the rioting in black lives
matter
someone who's pro-2a but would choose to
live in minneapolis like they'd have to
be a psychopath right
thanks right well i did read a book once
that confirmed it so i guess i'm a
psychopath now
there you go thanks grossman yeah you're
a hero i'm only half kidding i mean
people are leaving people are leaving
the city i don't want to live in this
place
i can't imagine this as we move down
this path
to where you get prominent progressive
channels with millions of followers
praising and defending child stripping
i'm like
that's not going to last because when
you have like with the james younger
case in texas
where a dad says my son is my son and
the mom says my son is actually my
daughter and is trans
at a certain point a parent is going to
be like do not touch my child
yeah and then and then what i mean it'll
change when parents actually value their
children
you know like we talk about the public
school system right this is i mean this
is the i've used this example a couple
times before but it's my classic
frustration
is you have a middle class dad a father
and he has a kid who's in public school
and that father
every time you see him all you're going
to hear him do is rail against the
public school system
while he works his nine to five and his
kid goes to the public school system
and so for 18 years you just hear the
same thing public school system blah
blah blah
then susie turns 18 and dad takes 140
thousand dollars that he has saved up
and sends
susie to college where he continues to
complain and she ends up a communist and
hates him
yeah what like you failed as a father
i saw i think it was a reddit post where
a guy was like my daughter came back
you know for for a break for like spring
break or something
and when she left she was a normal you
know high school kid
graduated now her head's shaven she's
wearing weird makeup and she tells me
she hates me and i'm evil
it's like yeah well pay attention i'll
tell you this man
this idea that parents had where it's
like
i can ignore what my child's my child's
life is like
what they're being taught and what
they're being indoctrinated with i can
ignore
the the raising of my child and they'll
be okay
psychotic yes people are people care
more about their
their their pet's life than their child
their their child has become
a pet that they put up with and they you
know feed
it and then whatever but like i think
that's very serious i i have to say this
with with
absolute like seriousness family raising
and raising a family
is that your most important
responsibility as a as a parent
i guess i have to say this uh not having
kids yet of my own
but is to pass your values onto your
children so that they will be
you know so that if because if they're
your values you believe in them
right so maybe they want their kids to
be commies who hate them no i mean
it's it's the same thing like if let's
just say i have a any insert any value
if i believe that the second amendment
is a
moral value i don't think that people
owning firearms is a utility
against an uh against a foreign
government or or against corruption in
argument i don't i don't believe it is a
utility argument although it could have
one
i think that owning a firearm firearms
ownership on the citizen level is
fundamentally a
moral problem it is moral that people
say
this is my country i have investiture in
it it is my land i am a part of it
i am part of this country therefore i
take personal responsibility within my
community
to be able to do that so if i think
that's a value and then i have a kid and
say you believe whatever you want man i
don't want you i don't want to push my
beliefs on you
you don't believe those things they're
just a fashion statement to you you kind
of just passed that belief on to me
because
if we were in a tribe 7000 years ago and
there were
wild animals trying to attack and kill
the tribe if you were if you didn't pick
up
a spear and attack and defend you were
acting immorally it is your moral duty
as a human
to produce a weapon and defend your
tribe
from that's kind of why we're seeing
what we're seeing i suppose
but it's the government's monopoly on
violence that i think is keeping
everything in check because i'll tell
you this man there's probably a lot of
people who are
more traditionalist and not even
necessarily far right or even that
particularly that conservative who are
looking at what's going on with the
abuse of children in this country
particularly in cities
and their eyes are probably twitching
and veins are throbbing
and it's scary stuff i mean how can this
country survive
i see this this poll about the
balkanization you know 37.2 percent want
to want to uh
want to break apart and i say i get it i
watched that video of that kid stripping
for money at
a at a club with men throwing money at
them and i totally understand why people
say
get new york and la out of my country
because what else do you do about it i
don't know i'm legislating
federally led i don't know more more
local law
that's a culture issue they that what
you're talking about
no um city council came together and
said we're going to make a child's
a child strip in front of other people
that was a cultural decision
and those people do not have your
culture and their culture is an
opposition of yours it's incompatible
right you're running the the the great
the the i'm going to use this as
sarcastically as possible this great
idea that all roads lead to rome that
all religions are just the same
is ridiculous because all of them
describe evil in
completely different ways i i think it's
funny there's like this weird meme where
people keep calling me an atheist i
don't know where that came from what
well you're you're agnostic right you're
a thief no i'm not i believe in god
okay he's a theist i'm kind of agnostic
oh yeah i am a
no i'm not i'm not theistic in the sense
that i follow script or anything like
that but i believe in god how do you
fall in this realm or for like religious
yeah yeah
you'd call it i'm a reformed christian
yeah what's that name uh so reformed is
sort it somewhat follows from the
tradition of calvin
and there's there's i mean you can go
multiple different ways but think of it
as like within the christian
within what people refer to as
christianity there are certain things
that are sort of
necessary doctrine so when you talk
about praxis
that's a that comes from a religious
concept of prac doxy doctrine
versus praxis practice practice you know
so orthodoxy how
what what is the the accepted belief in
orthopraxy what is the accepted practice
so for me one of the things is in the
tension between the
um and the tension between human free
will and the sovereignty of god right so
if god knows all things
is all-powerful and is outside of time
do we really have free will
i think it's i think that free will is
something i live as though i have free
will but according to doctrine i think
that
the sovereignty of god is much more
important i think it's much more closer
to being true
so that means did you see that lightning
strike bro
yeah the uh i heard about it those that
the george floyd
mural getting struck by lightning
blowing out the brick wall
i checked the weather on that day and it
was sunny with scattered clouds
in the photos the ground was mostly dry
which is to insinuate it rained very
briefly just enough for a lightning
strike on the george floyd mural
that that's freaky stuff a lot of people
were saying it was a sign got it spoken
there's memes of a hand coming out of
clouds with a gun
and i'm like you know look sometimes
lightning strikes buildings happens
actually all the time and this one
happened have a george floyd mirror on
it the agnosticism in me really shows as
one person told me hey one lightning
strike doesn't prove anything and i
thought well
it doesn't disprove it either that's
true yeah well
what's the chance that the lightning
would strike a building
and blow up or focusing on a lot not
if the human mind is a bunch of
electrical magnetic
i've seen some stuff man like i'll tell
you if there was one thing that
really like snapped something in my head
it was watching that kid strip on stage
and the left cheering for and clapping
and seeing that four-year-old little
girl twerking and they're cheering for
it and i'm like
dude i am like left lib hippie on a farm
live and let live be happy and they're
they're doing these things to kids like
there is evil in this world man
then that lightning strike with
everything i've seen i'm like man
you know go ahead can you make me wonder
can you finish how you were about to say
something about the dichotomy between
orthodoxy and ortho
oh not the dichotomy between orthodoxy
and proxy but the tension between human
free will and the sovereignty of god
so like so our the question is are
humans actually do we have free will
and like we think so like we generally
think so but from like a theological
doctrine it's these two uh concepts
exist in tension
and so while i so what i would say is i
believe and i believe that
um god is sovereign as in like
everything from gravity
is the continual action of god we are
living through god's continual process
of creation
um and so in some ways it's determined
but we're not capable of seeing in that
and the measurement or the the mechanism
of its determination being determined is
bigger than our capacity to observe
gravity all all of reality because of in
the beginning god created the heavens
and the earth
right so if god created then i don't
think that he created the earth and just
said okay cool let's see how this
experiment plan plays out i think that
the act that we're seeing the world that
we're seeing right now is
he's continuously upholding the world as
it is so the
the the professor of mine that i studied
under said salt dissolves in water
every time the same time because god is
consistent and he and he
you by his will has salt dissolve in
water every time
exactly the same way he the what we call
laws of nature are just his continual
action
so that's that's on a metaphysics level
and then from like
historical and and i be what i believe
evil is so the problem of evil how can a
all-perfect god all-knowing god and our
all-powerful all-knowing and all-good
god
create a world where there's evil this
is not a very intelligent question
people usually use it as a stumping
question
it's not a very intelligent question
because people have been answering it
for 2000 years if you're just coming to
that now and you don't read a book
you're not asking the question honestly
i'm just gonna jump to the table
it's a difficult question and multiple
theologians have answered it over the
time
but the one that i fall under is that
evil is the absence of god
so man sin entered the world
as human kinds humankind sinned against
god and they became
less than they were intended to so it's
the absence of god if god is the source
of life he's the source of
all these other things so that's kind of
and that's on on on what is evil what is
good
good god writes the laws of morality in
the same way that he writes the laws of
science they're absolute we just think
of laws in human creations where
i can break a human law and get away
with it but you can't break the law of
god and get away with it
so do you think that like that lightning
strike is god coming back to the scene
in some way or something no i don't i
don't you think just sometimes lightning
strikes
yeah i don't i think it's very dangerous
to
pretend that me a human can interpret
something as the will of god when he
gave us
scripture and now and and we have and
that's hard enough for me to comprehend
i'm so i don't i do believe that god
acts in our world
i'm just very very very skeptical when i
see something happen
so that because i don't want to get
caught up in this this
storm of like for lack of better words i
don't want to i don't think it's
respectful for even a theological sense
to
interpret everything as if it's like oh
god is speaking to me
i think that's a little dangerous is it
taking psychedelics no
but to be consistent if the act of salt
dissolving in water is the process of
god
using like his power to make it happen
like continuing a scientific process
then how would it not be consistent to
say that something like a lightning
strike could be interpreted as god
moving and acting
let me rephrase myself then yes you're
correct in that i will i will see
that point yes it is god chose that to
happen at that point at that time in
that place
right my i however i don't necessarily
i think i need to be humble in
recognizing
is that that event happening the
significance of it is so that i will
think something or i will see it is it a
sign is the question i'm saying
and i'm very very cautious about seeing
things as signs
because those are things that you have
to take very seriously for example
if you you know if i say god spoke to me
and told me to do something or whatever
and i don't do it
i am either lying or that is an absolute
sin
because i have irrefutable evidence
within the construct of my mind that he
came to me and said
drink that soda and i don't drink that
soda i'm just basically saying
well you are not god anymore i don't
care and it's
ma it's a huge issue there but then on
on the flip side if you
say that god told me to do something and
he did not you are lying
in my mind that is that is the form that
is literally
speaking for god that is taking god's
name in vain yeah
very much so and so it's it's one of
those things where like for when you
when you
address these issues from a very serious
level if you take your
faith seriously you will not be flippant
with
lucid interpretations as if there are
signs specifically from god telling you
to do something
because you will take any you take
interpretation very very very seriously
and that's what i see the big difference
in i used to take signs too seriously
it was driving me slowly insane like i
would see two birds flying and i'd be
like that means that i will find love
and it was like
you're going nuts crossland take a step
back
he's become self-aware everyone maybe
from maybe there is a grand arcing
coercive plan but i don't know i think
it falls in the same line of conspiracy
theory in the sense of it it produces
some of the same effects it's just a
religious version of it
because like yeah when you're seeing
everything as the conspiracy of the
illuminati
you go crazy because you're you lose
your ability to
accurately perceive to your own ability
the actual world
because everything has to be seen
through the lines of the conspiracy do
you think god has
in functions with intention absolutely
yeah he's a person how would you define
intention
i i think we understand intention
because we understand that god has a
will
i think i i wouldn't i wouldn't say i
understand
my intention and i'm going to ascribe
that to god i think that
you and i to you and i we have an
intention because i have both desires
and when i
s when i pick up this magazine i'm
picking it up to do something when i'm
writing
if my writing is not an act of intention
if i'm not creating out of intent
am i creating no and so
the act of creation itself is a sign of
intent
well there you go no how about we take
some super chats i love it
if you have not already give that like
button a nice little tap subscribe to
this channel go to timcast.com become a
member
i'm just looking forward to waking up on
monday and seeing that new site and just
finally it looks really nice because i'm
sure um within the next
i think next uh what are we at about a
week from now
week and a half we're gonna start
working on the production for the new
show
the name has not been released yet we're
gonna secure all the domains and all the
social medias and all that stuff and
then we're gonna actually have some
writers who
do um i don't know the right word is i
don't want to say investigation
but like you know the x-files you know
mis i think the x-file is kind of a cool
way to like think about it have you guys
you guys seen the x-files right
it's not just one thing it's it's kind
of like looking in
from a skeptic's point of view of like
what these things could possibly be and
exploring these spooky stories and
having fun with it
so that's coming baby smash that like
button let's see we got
michael loose says i'm an audio engineer
and composer i've worked with the tennis
channel wwe and wrote music for a local
award writing indie films
daily emails aren't getting your
attention so i knew i had to step it up
more samples coming your way
well the issue is um we we might have
somebody
and we have thousands of emails and i
can't answer all of them so
you know i i apologize man it's it's
it's
it kind of sucks you know like you're
like hey i wanna send my email in but
there's like there's only so many people
here who can actually read every email
and
we literally couldn't do it it's kind of
like if you're looking for a drop of
water and someone hands you a bucket of
water you're like where are all the
drops
they're all in there but it doesn't it
just looks like it's like it's like i
said i need a glass of water and they
hand me a bucket so i took a cup and i
scooped out a cup of water and
all of that other water is saying no but
i want to be in the cup
it's like sorry bro like you know we're
not we're not saying we're not happy
with you being water but you know we can
only fit so much in the cup
it's a sign from god that's right
all right let's see broken word says if
the point of the show is to red pill ian
then the red pill is the only pill ian
hasn't tried by his own admission
i want to go so deep that was so good
on so many things my mind's i would like
to hear that chat again mate super chat
again
we need a meme of like all these
different colored pills in front of ian
yeah and then the next panel is he's
eating them all and he's just blasted
out of his mind but the red one's just
sitting there like the one you didn't
eat
dude i thought i feel like i got red
pilled when i saw
what was it aaron russo's was it what
did aaron russo do that movie he did
2007.
it wasn't loose change was it loose
change zeitgeist loose change all these
things about like 9 11 the war in iraq i
feel like i got
so red pilled and now i just have to
keep sane
like not most people didn't didn't get
it back then and
and i just liked you just stay cool man
stay under the radar
chill and find a solution but i would
love to talk about some of this stuff
um i just don't talk about on the show
all right redeemed one says my wife is a
five foot tall latina from mexico who
supported trump months before i did
she regularly buys recoil magazine and
the looks she gets at checkout are
priceless
oh thank you i'm happy to hear that and
by the way you also can't
subscribe to the magazine on our website
recoil web that's the best way
to get it for the best price
consistently awesome do you ever put bar
codes in the magazine
you can scan it'll take you to a secret
web page
let's talk after i like it oh snap i
like it
chuckin shank says as a 26 year old
first-time father to be
the crew and the good people they're
surrounding themselves with gives me
great hope
thank you from the three of us oh
congratulations
that's exciting thank you doug smith
says i just noticed someone gave you
five dollars more than me so here's
another ten dollars
oh there you go unacceptable
all right let's see um
men's mensicoski if trust is broken in
one place
restrictions are imposed everywhere ccp
and the biden administration
interesting keith mccracken says i
understand to some extent to why the
cuban people use the american flag as a
symbol against their government
what i think is that they need to create
a flag to represent their freedom
it was hot though i was feeling you for
a second lydia that was hot did you guys
feel how hot it was like 30 seconds ago
yeah it was starting to kick up yeah
i'm trying to yeah i'm sorry we have a
new air conditioner in the studio
even though we're moving from this room
to a new studio room which is going to
be crazy
it looks cool the table is going to be
mounted to the ceiling
oh super creative guys working on it so
is it like hanging
or is it okay it'll be hanging from like
some bars the the
the bars that we hang it from are going
to be used to mount the cameras and the
lights and everything
so it's going to be really interesting
we might have to put them on the cameras
on the walls though we'll see how we get
it
it's going to be fun the rooms
technically a little bigger
but the ceiling's a standard ceiling
whereas this one we have this elevated
ceiling so it gives you like more
space yeah this one's an a-frame the one
down there is flat
yeah yeah yeah because this one's
actually on top of that one that's true
but it'll be cool yeah yeah
the ac will make sense there sorry about
that guys no worries i kind of like the
temperature change
all right let's see malzy says good
evening timothy you have a tremendous
responsibility to tell the truth
only put forth that which can withstand
the onslaught also i'm relieved to see
you don't wear toe rings thanks you oh
is that because of the vlog
i was like they got a clip of your foot
yeah yeah yeah cause i was walking
around on the mulberry
exposed i was when you go to pick
mulberries they're
everywhere so your feet turn purple and
then i made a joke about like someone
gonna play on celebrity feed i guess
but they're all like covered in purple
stains that was the joke that's weird
weird creepy yeah mulberry only fans
foot yeah i'm not a fan of mulberries
special
really yeah i don't like them the
wineberries are
kind of boring right yeah they're pretty
the good news is um
we got tons of paw paw oh good yeah we
got a lot of papa
and it's like hard to grow so we're
really excited for this uh if you go to
our sister page
uh recoil off grid we do have articles
like one of them is
pawpaw is actually a really good
survival food perfect so like if you
want to go for more like the survivalist
side it's all off grid we that's another
magazine of ours
and they're yeah off grid looks cool
it's yeah
it's really neat john doe says mr pool
we've been trying to reach you about
your vehicle's extended warranty
seriously it had to happen oh yeah we
used to get a bunch of those
garett says in regards to classifying
the american left they are race-based
marxists
the progressive stack exemplifies a
racial caste system
race-based marxist support
dehumanization to children rbm has more
in common with germany with salutes than
usa rbm is evil interesting
people don't like vosh yep i know it
people are saying a lot of stuff that's
right yep
ironclad vr says wisdom was traded for
intelligence conversation on difficult
difficult ideas help to build wisdom and
fine-tune our intelligence on a
different note
i'm developing a game and want to work
under the tim cast umbrella how do
uh send it to pitches at timcast.com
let's see what that game is
um i will say knowledge is knowing that
a tomato is a fruit
wisdom is knowing not to put it in a
fruit salad
what's that saying the continuation is
that philosophy is trying to figure out
if ketchup is a smoothie
[Laughter]
that's awesome yeah i have never heard
that before i saw that the other day i
was like
oh yeah well as as someone who went to
school for philosophy i'm both offended
and impressed i know it's true
yeah but no ketchup's not a smoothie how
do you figure
well uh these are cold no because you
don't throw tomatoes into a blender to
make ketchup
oh how do they make it well to first you
have to get specific tomatoes they have
to be reduced
cook it down you cook it down you add
sugar then you get a tomato paste
then you mix like vinegar and spices and
that is knowledge
there you go yeah yeah so to make a
smoothie you take
you can literally walk outside grab it
i'll make a tomato smoothie i'll walk
outside grab a bunch of tomatoes throw
them in a blender
and then pour some ice in it blend it up
and i got a tomato smoothie
sounds pretty good that's not the same
thing okay if you took strawberries
and you put them in a pot and you you
mash them up and cook them down
yeah you would get a jam yeah so it's
more like a jam
yeah then it's lots of ketchup more of a
jam
because after you get the tomato paste
you then have to process it further okay
yeah come on come on all right all right
sorry sorry trying to try to pull this
philosophy junk
ketchup you didn't even get me started
what's mayonnaise
oh gosh eggs it's it's actually yeah
i've made mayonnaise before it's really
fascinating yeah it's like it's an
emulsion
yeah yeah it's crazy
then you said a rock it's an emulsion
okay so rocks are emulsion
i mean opals are an emulsion as well
really that's why i love them the rock
weird it's crazy we'll talk about this
after so
we'll get into it daniel
bundrick says leftism leftism is what
happens when someone decides to give in
and just wear the golden handcuffs
you know um i think it's
a lot of there's a reason young people
are leftists and it's because the
establishment manipulates
ignorant people yeah to gain power yeah
and so
you can have someone like me people are
like someone commented tim abandoned
leftism or whatever and i'm like dude
what left and right means is nebulous
it's like tribal signifiers or whatever
but you have young people who are very
much pro-establishment like that
18-year-old girl who went with the
administration to like support vaccines
and children or whatever it's like these
are these kids
would gladly go and cheer on the
establishment the state
they graffiti black lives matter you
know it's like the joke i was making
somebody will be like writing
walmart.com
in graffiti like yeah f the
establishment pro walmart you're like
bro that is the establishment what are
you doing
you're not fighting anybody you're part
of the machine but that's what they do
they prey upon
young people that's what you get
so they grow up and then they're like
hey wait a minute that was bs
yeah hopefully and it's not just the
the act of growing up that will that
will help you wake up so you gotta
kind of look for it maybe i did anyway
you have to humble yourself you have to
seek it out jonathan galterani says you
just
made the amazon device go off in my
house go off across my house
that's powerful there was there was this
big thing that happened when google
did a commercial where they said you
know it's like whatever the catchphrase
call phrases for the device and then
everyone's devices would turn on
oh yeah so now i think what they've done
is all these
voice activated devices when they do
commercials specifically program that
sound not to trigger the device
how interesting but it was really
annoying when i was watching tv
and they would say the name of the thing
and then it would turn on and go i'm
sorry
fix your stupid crap it's also kind of
funny that they didn't see that
happening
i know right it makes sense why you
wouldn't but yeah google i heard was
very disorganized when they had google
plus
and youtube it would be like two two
hands not knowing what the other hand
was doing
right and they were like developing two
kind of parallel systems that
worked similar but totally different
that sounds right you guys ready for
this one
i'm gonna read this one i'm doing it do
it to everybody who's got one of those
amazon devices
you're gonna love this alexa
order speechless controlling words
controlling minds
by michael knowles
what you gonna say a best-selling option
is speechless
she's talking to us right now
controlling lines a print version it's
19.89
can you guys hear that it's in the cart
it's in the cart but she didn't buy it
19 how do i confirm it i don't know
okay somebody's super
so that that was ranek who super chatted
that and now i'm wondering how many
people listening to the show are going
stop
stop stop stop it's not powerful michael
michael's going to notice a huge spike
in sales sponsor
we sold 25 000 uh copies just
instantly ladies and gentlemen it is in
your cart that's right can you
help can you be held accountable i don't
know like you've got a live stream
something happens and so now they're
like uh tim i need you to pay my amazon
20 bucks i was just reading this free
speech i can say what i want it's it's
amazon's fault for her so i'm curious
someone people are chatting
she's ordering at omg
shut up alexa that reineck that was the
best
i saw that and i was like if i read that
she's gonna actually order hey
yours is in your cart wasn't it yeah we
didn't buy it so
yeah it doesn't auto buy just because
you said it okay a whole new version of
mass media marketing
people shouldn't buy it though he hit
number one yeah he did good alexa
he's one of those people that i felt
like i knew for a long like
growing up kind of when i when i met or
saw him and met him mm-hmm i liked that
did you ever listen to his podcast he's
very personable i think that's only only
a little bit like
i catch snippets i've never met him it's
cool he's super cool all right let's
read this we got butters oregano he says
just body used springfield 1911 and 10
millimeter
and the previous owner committed
sacrilege by putting what does he say
trijicon
rmr on it oh trojan rmr yeah he put our
red dots out on it
your thoughts on pistols with red dots
forest they're the future if you're not
going to get on that board then you're
just
really yeah they're the future
absolutely interesting i don't think
they're going to be universal there are
certain applications where it doesn't
make sense but you got to remember
like that's not it's kind of a new thing
putting red dots on pistols
is sort of a it's it's it's in its
adolescent years we're just starting to
get
uh handguns designed to be to have a red
dot sight on top of it
it's easier to explain but i mean if and
if you know what i'm talking about uh
most pistols have iron sights but this
one here this revolver it's got a little
red dot sight so if you think of like
you know
it's the so that's the revolver has one
but like
everyday carry defense handguns are now
coming either directly out of the box
like the springfield hellcat's a really
good example uh the rdp does but
that's it what i'm gonna say is red dots
for those who are
not real that are like hesitant of
getting into red dots they have a
distinct set of advantages and a very
small set of
disadvantages what are those the the the
higher end advantages is
we're seeing generally that once you get
past the the growing curve
performance goes up pretty well also
when you're if you have to take shots at
distance
the red dot is much faster and another
really good example
that i use is just for like human
mechanics when i'm using a red when i'm
using a pistol with iron sights
what i do is my eye looks at what my
target is and then the focal plane comes
back to the iron sight
and then so my focal plane is actually
on the iron sight when i'm using a red
dot
i look at the my target and i put the
dot on it and i don't change my focal
point
so from a biomechanical method it does
make some sense
it's one less movement if you count
moving your focal plane
you think the average person's accuracy
would improve with a red dot on the
handgun if you're
yes with a caveat it the girl the the
growing curve the learning curve on red
dots
mounted on handguns is awkward why is
that
because it's it's it's the it should i
don't know how to say it otherwise
it's you need to build the muscle memory
which is not the right term i know don't
go
nuclear on me but you need to build the
habitual
movements because aligning iron sights
is a lot easier because you know
when you when you're off you know where
you're off because you know where the
sights are whereas when you're off on
the red dot
when it's not in the window because your
pistol's canted you don't know which way
it is so you see people
fishing for it and what you need to do
is you need to spend the time dry firing
it's not it doesn't take long and some
models is easier um to get over that
curve but you need to
practice with it until you can reliably
every time i draw that handgun and i
present it
that dot is right in the center of that
glass so much so that it's practiced
once you get past that curve which you
know could be
can be accomplished with 100 rounds and
a decent amount of dry fire practice
which is just practicing without
ammunition
otherwise 500 rounds but it's a
deliberate thing
you can and and the one of the reasons
why a lot of people don't like red dots
is because they don't want to put in the
work to be able to use them
understandably so if you're very casual
they also do have other downsides like
they can be
they can be damaged by weather they can
get dirty they have
they require a battery these are all
disadvantages but they're those
advantages are getting smaller and
smaller and smaller and smaller the
aimpoint acro is a self-concealed
um little red dot that goes on a pistol
it's not going to be damaged by the
environment in the same way that a
trijicon rmr
is so yeah if it's a sacrilege to put it
on i'd say
the first sacrilege is that it's a 10
millimeter 1911. yeah i figured
but i mean you know you do you boo
[Laughter]
all right patrick conover says tim rail
guns like flamethrowers
and muzzle loaders are not classified as
firearms and would likely similarly be
unregulated
at least at a federal level do you think
muzzleloaders are classified as firearms
by youtube
uh yes yes they would do it and then the
answer is as soon as you could
effectively produce rail guns in your
house they become guns
right the moment that you can make them
then the government will be like oh hey
hold on hold on hold on
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait hold on what if what if
you hear me out
you have imagine this is a metal a metal
circle
with pipes coming out there's you know
so you've got
three i mean you got basically eight
eight pipes right
and then you have a big uh um magazine
tube
loaded with slugs and what happens is a
steam engine
spins the disc rapidly and the way it's
it's it's made is that
once every time it comes around a slog
it gets
slinged it grabs it then slings it as it
spins rapidly
would that be a gun that's a steam
thinking the railgun is an
electromagnetic sling
thank you for saying that word so what
i'm describing has actually been built
before
it steam power spins this disc at a
really high rate of speed
and then it grabs a slug and then whips
it really fast and fires them forward
that's like similar to the steam-powered
gatling gun or something
crazy right yeah it's is it considered
ballistic if it's
if it's thrown is that a considered
ballistic if you throw something well
ballistic doesn't refer to
it being fired out of a projectile
through through
pressure a ballistic is is
it's a thing just moving yeah
ballistics ballistics is is in the it
regards the trajectory and impact of a
target of a projectile so it would be
ballistic
a railgun but it's still not considered
a rail cannon or whatever i mean they're
called rail guns right
a spinny steam thingy yes
jack's mountain t-dude says someone gave
more than me again so here's 35 dollars
which is the price of our essential oil
for muscle soreness
relieved free local delivery go army hey
nice good for them
well matt bowler says as i mentioned
yesterday you need to analyze the data
further further
metadata is incredibly important as you
know tim considering your objective
analysis of journalism
we're gonna we're gonna eventually have
some data journalists too so they can
better go through the stuff than
me in my like surface level opinion
which is probably full of inaccuracies
turk longwell says tim are you hard
pivoting from civil war to balkanization
also i do daily yougov polls we
uh we need more people taking them be
the voice um
i mean look when i say things like that
it's usually meant to be like a
hey this thing's possible if these
things keep happening a lot of people
seem to think that
if i say something where it's like wow
this kind of thing happening is like
puts us on this track they're like tim
has predicted this will happen then
something funny happens when it does
happen they're like you predicted this
and i'm like i just gave a bunch of
vague possibilities it's like
nostradamus man
not hard to do but then when it doesn't
happen they're like you said it would
happen i'm like i kind of didn't
i can't see the future man i'm just
saying like i think some things are more
possible
so we i you know i was talking with sean
fitzgerald the other day like after the
show and i was just like
everything we've seen since the start of
the culture war has only gotten worse
considering that keeps happening i'm
inclined to believe it will get worse
that doesn't mean the world's going to
end our lives are gonna suck like people
live through these things
and they get by i think people will
individually be fine
as a whole though the united states will
experience some dark times i mean look
what's happening with
the white house being like we're overtly
including with big tech to censor people
and we're gonna make it worse
like yeah who would have thought we'd
come to that point when we saw big tech
censoring someone for saying learn to
code
that it would turn into the white house
press secretary saying we want
cross-platform censorship
for anybody posting information that is
in inaccurate
it's like wow that escalated
somewhat quickly yeah i would say so so
i always say this
hey maybe today's the day that everyone
just lays down their figurative sword
and says i don't want to be engaged in
the political battles anymore
i want to hug my neighbor and we're
going to hold hands and sing into the
sunshine
is that is it possible sure i just don't
think that's like
right because the real thing is when
people stop thinking and have clear
thought and have no thought
that's when we're really going to find
human peace it's not thinking i love you
i want i want it's it's when there is no
thought
we will get there eventually maybe not
all of us but you can
we will achieve human peace when we're
all dead no no just kind of meditating
when we're able to control our thoughts
and not not have these wild thoughts
just pop into our head constantly when
you can clear your mind and have access
to your
emotions i think that would be when we
have the moral discipline to
not engage in immoral activity
and humility um um what are they what
are they
when you go and you confess confession
helps that a lot clear your mind
all right ry lyon says my son was born
this week he is the joy of my life
already
this super chat is for him yeah that it
helps you keep this country free and the
culture american
you are doing the right thing for your
child by supporting our work
uh i mean that i'm half kidding i think
we do good work here and i think we're
gonna continue to do good work and i'm
gonna try my best and
everybody in the teamcast team is going
to try to present a
reasonable pragmatic and principled
approach to providing people with
information so they can make up their
minds as to what they think
should be happening but right now the
media apparatus today is
we should just frame things in a way
that people do things that we want
that's called lying to people
so if i congratulations yeah so if
somebody does something that is good
uh if you if you lie to someone and they
do something as good do they get the
credit of morality
if you deceive if they're not doing it
by their own will that's kind of like
the end
of um what's that movie with uh dr
manhattan
yeah they lied ozymandias lied to the
human race to prevent world war
did he do the right thing were they what
was your question exactly deontology
versus utilitarianism yeah
yeah simply put right like if you're
lying to prevent
a tragedy are you good the needs of the
many do you believe the needs of the
many outweigh the needs of the few
no not necessarily that was spock that's
utilitarianism yeah because
typically you can overrule those views
that the needs of the many over
that way the needs of the few like uh
the bad guy in king's men yeah too many
is bad as bad as too few so you got to
be careful
well another way you could refer you
could form utilitarianism is that we are
capable of
measuring the the net goodness and we
determine whether thing is moral or
immoral if it produces a net goodness
so if i kill ten thousand people to save
a hundred thousand people
well a hundred thousand people survive
so that's a net good
that's the ultimate that's the ultimate
that's the ultimate
dilemma of utilitarianism is okay well
no we don't
really think we actually don't think
that way the trolley yeah
there's a there is a train coming uh-oh
and there are five people
tied to the train track get them save
them all and as the train's coming
you walk over and there's a lever if you
pull the lever it will divert the train
onto a new track with only one person
you will save the five but kill the one
do you pull the lever
probably so you would that person would
survive if you don't intervene
he said yeah but i'm not gonna let five
people die for no reason if
dude what a terrifying situation that's
being the american president is what it
seems like who's gonna live
that's your decision this person on the
on the off track
is safe you would have to condemn them
to death to decide those people those
five people deserve to live
that's brutal man yeah most people say
they wouldn't pull the lever
they would let them get involved well
doing nothing is also a choice it's not
about not getting involved it's about
taking action that would kill a person
right right now it's like
something happened that set this this
course of action that will kill five
people and i have to tell that person's
family i
killed him to save those people like if
it was because i think if it is a very
base level if we're if it's a truck if
i'm forming a tribe
having five more people in the tribe is
probably going to be a lot better than
having one more person if it's just me
like the six of us can get a lot done
build houses
irrigation me and that one person good
luck so
you're still making an argument out of
utility like yeah it does come into
a problem you know another another
format of kind of the issue too would be
if i you if i threaten you with violence
and have the capacity to do it if i
figuratively point a gun at you and then
give you one and tell them to point at
ian and
tell you to do do e and n are you
considered
are you morally reliable held liable for
your decision yes absolutely
you chose to you chose the value to
value your own life
right over your morality and the life of
ian my favorite meme
is there's there's two two memes in the
trolley problem that are my favorite one
is it's one track loaded with people
and the trolley just mowing them all
down and it says the trolley can stop at
any time but it would disrupt corporate
profits to the shareholders
that was good but then the other one is
the train is is on like
it's a fully drawn picture the train's
going through a tunnel and there's like
mountains
and there's one guy who's dead and one
guy's standing there and it says
the you've finally defeated the man
who's been tying all these people to the
train tracks
it's it's all over that's that's awesome
that one gets my respect i like those of
course it's all over
all right crandall logan says just join
the website and can't wait for the new
one to drop
will it be easier to search videos by
guest because i was looking for a
specific video on youtube and it was
probably censored
and was having trouble searching for it
on your website it will be way easier so
right now
we have like a placeholder website that
we we implemented and now we have like
big dev working like a great team
working on this new website
so that you can easily search by topic
by by name
all that stuff so uh it should
definitely be a lot easier but i will
say our our soft launch our target is
for monday
could change we'll see even when we do
launch
that's when the bugs happen and then we
get a thousand emails from people like
hey this bug happened and then we're
like oh what are we doing we're
desperately trying to fix it and help
everybody because you know how website
launches go
right but we're gonna title by guest
name right we do we do yeah
there you go so um that should help is
there a search mechanism on
on the new site yes you should be able
to just type in the guest name and it
should pop up that's
awesome yeah and there's also
recommended
feeds for the videos too so like old
ones will surface again and we're going
to be improving seo so like
you'll be able to find these videos and
uh there's a better mechanism for which
we can publish some of them for free or
like demo so like if there's a really
important conversation we're having that
we think shouldn't be behind a paywall
we can make it as like a a free trial
for people to like it's so important to
see a preview
like a like a two or three minute
preview from a video we're definitely
gonna decide if they want to sign up
we're working on a mobile app where
people can listen with the screen off
with your phone's asleep yes and we're
working on
previews for the episodes and things
like that that's cool that's a selling
point
previous selling mechanism brandon
aycock says
has ian read a history of money and
banking in the united states by murray
rothbard no if not
it might dramatically increase his
mentioning of the federal reserve after
reading it oh no
yeah dave smith because he's the famous
uh anarchist
murray rothbard possibly dave smith
spoke very highly of him uh
carol was also talking about him
apparently yeah murray rothbard
oh man it's uh it's it's so difficult to
get through every single super chat but
we tried
kenny blankenship said just watched lex
friedman's latest podcast with michael
malus
michael broke down while talking about
the nazi invasion of russia it was a
powerful and surreal moment i was
floored
wow did you guys see that i saw that
that was wow they were talking about
this song about
when the germans invaded operation
barbarossa and all of a sudden
all these people were living their lives
and then at four o'clock
the bombs started dropping and it's like
how fast things can change and mike
mike's michael's
mike i call him mike buddy his grandma
was there wow
and and his great-grandmother this
wasn't that day i don't think but had to
make a choice
to to dive her her son and her daughter
her daughter were both there and she she
dove on her son
to protect him wow and his grandmother
her daughter remembered that her whole
life that his great-grandmother chose
her brother
i'm actually wow wow that sounds wow
brutal
amazing dudes that's another part of his
talks about anarchy
i get it coming from a soviet the soviet
system of how a government can go
horribly wrong that now i see how he can
see the value in anarchy so much
so much more yeah
all right jack's mountain t-dude says my
first super chat didn't get read
so none of my super chats make sense jax
mountain tea is a disabled veteran owned
tea company
and we'd love to sponsor you but there's
no email on your about
uh about paige um pitches
no they're the it could be on uh uh it
should be
if you go to youtube.comtimcast my other
channel is definitely there
so um check that one out for sure i will
say about michael malus man that dude is
so positive like he's so upbeat you know
he just you can't get him down he's
laughing the whole time he's he's he's
having fun with it he's seen hard things
yeah man why hard times make strong men
huh
he's like a white wizard that's right
white pillar
back to final fantasy yeah already back
there
blackrock beacon says do you believe man
and god can disagree
and that man can influence god's will if
not what about abraham arguing with god
to spare sodom and gomorrah
and god conceding to him this is a
common theme in the old testament
i i think so i think that's why prayer
functions
personally or perhaps it was not
that god was conceding to him but that
god was only
god was absolutely willing or intending
to spare sodom and gomorrah for
those reasons but needed man to come to
the understanding as to why
so my parents actually said that they
were testing his faith by asking him to
do that um they brought up the example
of him being asked to sacrifice his son
as well like that's an insane thing to
ask a parent especially someone
uh to who's waited so long for a son no
i was practicing this thing where
instead of saying words i would think
them to someone like
hello yeah and it would have a similar
effect they could read the body language
so it would have
like a form of communication and then i
started to think that
i was tapping into like the collect
there's a collective consciousness and
you can like hijack it
and like command it almost yeah i don't
i don't really buy into the collective
consciousness as like a hive mind
i really don't buy into that i think
when we talk about collective
consciousness it's just trends across
generations like it's it's consistencies
like
that's what i think of it as it's it's
not prescriptive it's descriptive
um and then yeah man has to wrestle god
allows men to wrestle with god so that
they know
that he is god all right bearpost says
many founding fathers wrote and believed
that the constitution will not work for
a people that don't have religious
morals or good principles
this is mandatory and that's and that's
we've uh what we've lost
gener generationally yeah yeah i agree
oh yeah absolutely morals like people
just want stuff let's i mean and it
doesn't it does not it's not even that
they just want stuff like you're talking
about earlier like some people think
that it is morally good for a young
child to strip in front of other people
right
right so that that's like they think it
is good
they will call good evil and they will
call evil good is it that they think the
stripping is good or that the
his right to choose to do it is what's
good they think that he's advocating for
marginalized people
and so that what he's doing is proving
something about the rights of
individuals or whatever and i'm just
like
kids taking off their clothes for money
is wrong
all right uh fico krusk says on the
topic of dumb laws
in the city of chico california
detonating a nuclear device within city
limits results in a five hundred dollar
fine oh wow
wow oh there there you go that'll stop
people
also could you imagine it's like after
the apocalypse somebody like
travels several months by like sale they
make it to russia
they find the totally destroyed kremlin
and there's like a vladimir putin with
his
his uniform all just destroyed his suits
ripped and tattered and he's sitting
there
and he's like all weak and injured and
the guy walks up to when he goes
i've traveled for three months to give
you this and then he slams a ticket on
the table says 500
fine and then putin
he also says also did you ever see the
signed copy of doctor strange i sent you
i didn't
oh it could be in the mail we got to go
get that mail picked up yeah i'm going
on monday
okay cool yeah that's me and then uh you
know i think we'll start opening the
mail on the vlog
i was thinking like sundays we'd do mail
day because we could send some cool
stuff we could send artwork all the time
yeah i want to i want to showcase some
of it yeah so go to go to if you go to
timcast.com in the about section there's
a p.o box
and we're going to start opening up the
mail and showcasing it
and uh that means some weird stuff will
probably end up and that's what's fun
about it
i get a lot of manifestos yeah you know
like people write personal like this is
what i believe
dude i've had people write like books
and send me like just to me
like it's like here's a letter for you
tim please read it it's 150 pages
i respect the work man but can you send
me the audiobook version yeah really
that's a good idea but i i we like big
stacks of people like i wrote this up in
response to what you're saying and i'm
like dude that is a lot of work to do
you should maybe publish that on your
own website yeah that'd be good
because like i can't i can't read that i
got time as an aside for the address
there is an
s on the end of the zip code you do not
need this s
leave it oh yes well get it fixed in the
new website monday exactly it confuses
the post office i talked about it
david meese says hey tim if you know the
channel mxr their entire channel has
been dem
uh demonized demonetized i was like
demonizing can't supposed to monetize
without demons
right that's right yeah uh yeah mixer is
that mxr is it mixer mxr
i've never heard of it yeah that sucks
though
j stewart says tim a tomato based fruit
salad is salsa
oh yeah interestingly they do put mango
in salsa oh it's so good too
i know yeah mango habanero salsa dude
man it's so good
corn it can be good it's not always good
true
needs to be slug pudding says ketchup is
tomato icing ah
no you might be wrong no no no no i can
make tomato icing
i can legit make a tomato please don't i
i have tomato jam
we made tomato jam we bought tomato jam
from from a farmer's market and you put
it on grilled cheese it's fantastic wow
we put tomato jam it's different it's
bacon jam
no vinegar in it yeah bacon jam yeah
yeah so
ketchup is a savory sauce
it's a sauce yeah sauce salty little
vinegar yeah
yeah i would like to take a you know
would be interesting to take a ketchup
recipe but do it with strawberries
oh yeah that'd be cool like vinegary and
savory
yeah or uh
but i read that you can substitute
pop-off or banana on any recipe oh
nice so we'll do it yeah yeah we'll do
like a pop-up bread
and we're gonna plant the seeds did you
see the blue uh
bananas apparently they taste like ice
cream get them overseas like in malaysia
or something
i need that wow i think i saw a picture
but that's about it yeah
it could have been fake news i don't
really like bananas that much
it's like it tastes like penicillin all
right uh
well i'll read this alejandro campo says
for the app i have had i've had the
membership but rarely watch the extra
content because i have to have the
window open
i am a trucker so i don't like having
the internet window open while i drive
we it's definitely like one of our top
priorities but that means we have to get
the app out first
and there's two things we're gonna do we
want to
start uploading not just the video
version but an audio version right
beneath it so you can press play and do
audio only
i think rumble might have some like that
i'm not sure but we need the new site to
launch we can start implementing these
things a lot of people
just listen they don't actually watch
the video of the bonus content so we
want to do an audio only version it's
way cheaper on bandwidth so it's better
for us in the long run
and then the only way to make it so that
you can listen to the show with this
with the phone off
is if we do a mobile app and that's
going to be another like
two months of development i've heard
that if you use brave you can minimize
it
put your phone on like off and then you
can still listen to it i've never
i've never tested it but yeah i've heard
this in comments repeatedly
i think that's what it is well the brave
browser is fantastic we're big fans of
the brave browser we use the brave
browser
it disables a lot of tracking much like
the freedom phone is saying they're
they're going to be doing
um haven't tried the freedom phone i
want to be short i want to make sure i
say i state that
but uh braves legit brave superhero i
love bro big fan
big fan of brave i i've used it for
everything yeah duck duck
number one brave yes sir we should get
those dudes on the show someday
brave dudes brave dudes oh yeah we
probably could yeah but
all right card 995 says you guys should
play trial by trolley on steam
that sounds great oh we got to watch
that movie hero with jet li
right yeah yeah yeah i want to watch
that okay
all right let's see we'll do we'll do a
couple more stephen 13 says
you know the soviets abused german
civilians german women were abused by
the red army in
in ways i can't say on youtube oh oh
yeah yeah yeah sure
jerome morrow says for the next show
instead of talking just use the
collective consciousness
and just think your comments to each
other i actually have youtube videos of
me doing that if you want to go back
into my old catalog on the crossmak
channel we i am so excited for this new
show we're doing on the mysteries and
the ghost stories and stuff
because so the format is going to be
there's going to be about a 15-minute
show with sound effects and everything
like legit
we're going to have shane who's writing
who writes these stories and they're
brilliant and amazing stories dude i was
just i'm reading through them i can't
put them down
we're going to make books based on the
stories we're going to do collections of
these these investigations
we're going to have like when he's
telling a story about you know
driving you'll hear like the engine when
he tells a story about like walking in a
store you'll hear like
the bell ring of a door opening it's
going to be a real show
and then followed by for members a
hangout conversation talking about it
so the free show for everybody which
will be on like youtube and itunes and
spotify will be like a 15 to 20 minutes
you know series and then people who are
members get to hang out with the crew as
they investigate explore in conversation
deeper like what does that mean how did
you find this and
make it a real hangout yeah i'm so
excited it's gonna be it's gonna be
amazing
i'm actually wondering if that could
actually become more prominent than
doing the political show because it's
more entertainment value
it works in tandem too they all kind of
work like a net
of of items it's gonna be fun man and
then once we do sports we're gonna do
tack video games movies the next show
we're planning is going to be cultural
uh commentary so that's more so
like black widow came out let's talk
about black widow did you see the movie
here's what i like and didn't like about
it spoiler alert and just
generally watching movies playing video
games and then we're doing the dnd show
the dnd show will probably come before
that so that's going to be once a week
where we have um so i'm looking for a dm
for the
or people that want to get involved but
i need like um a video a link to some
video you've done
of dnd just something that i can see so
i can see you in action because
seeing your text like a text thing isn't
enough to
get a feel for your work so i know it's
weird because most people don't record
them
i think we should should people reach
out to you if they're if they're dms
you can yeah it's just text isn't good
enough i need i need to get a feel for
your work and your style um
so to see it on a video helps a lot i
just mean like because normally we're
like go to jobs at tim cast but
i'm not going to be a good judge of a dm
you know you probably would yeah yeah
definitely hit me up on on twitter mines
or something with your content this
show's going to be fun because the idea
is
to have scenario like the the the the
stories
based around some kind of
socio-political like in some way related
to the modern
culture war and stuff like that and then
have people explore the situations much
like the trolley problem
see how they would react to them and how
they respond and you roll it down
they're gonna be censoring the spying
glasses you won't be able to see certain
types of information
exactly so you'll have a king or emperor
who will say well
you don't need swords because we have
nukes and f-15s yep
no they'll be like implicit your swords
are pathetic you can't stop us
you would need fire staffs and lightning
rods
and dragons which are illegal dragons
yup which they which they control yeah
contraband and then you actually have a
scenario where you have if we have like
you know five or six players going up
against one dragon and then you know
you know we'll see we'll see what
happens but um it's you know look for
people aren't familiar with dnd it's
mostly a bunch of people hanging out and
like laughing and joking and
like we'll be exploring a lot of
philosophical and moral
you know ideas with the show someone
emailed me saying we can't do individual
scenarios
it needs to be like a series like 13
episodes that explore one story
kind of like a show and that's actually
a really good idea because then
basically if someone writes
13 episodes basically it's almost like
watching a tv show like oh man what's
gonna happen next they call it
a campaign in d d language and that's
usually the way you work is like
some people go like for years with one
campaign you know from level one to
level 30.
uh over every four weeks they'll get
together and play
but or you can i think you could maybe
do different ones every week you could
hop into like sliders into different
bodies but
i like the idea of doing like a 13
episode campaign so it's like
a show and you're like oh man what's
what's going to happen to ian
oh dude like ian just got turned into a
chicken
what's going to happen next and then
it's like a lot better
yeah it turned me into a newt ladies and
gentlemen thanks for hanging out
on this friday night smash that like
button subscribe to this channel become
a member at timcast.com
and there's so much more in the works
tons of great articles
we've got i think we have like four
people hanging out here tomorrow when
we're gonna be filming the vlog and we
have a
couple of them wanna work here and there
are people you may have heard of so it's
gonna be really exciting because we're
gonna be adding tons and tons of people
to the to the team
producing more and more content and then
that way when i'm like old and feeble
there will be something that persists
outside of just the shows that i've been
doing there'll be other shows so that's
gonna be epic
you can follow the show at tim cast irl
on facebook and instagram
at tim underscore irl on tick tock
and uh we'll we'll be back tomorrow
morning with the vlog
which is i don't know if i can actually
say that
there's stuff in that video that's like
naughty because we made a joke we
combined uh um rollerblades with
they're called they're called roller
skis and so i combined the word ski
and street into one word and i think
youtube like not might not be happy with
what that word is but it's in the show
anyway so
youtube.comcastcastle we have a bunch of
episodes up that vlog is going to go
daily
where you see us hanging out today uh
ian had a huge crew outside picking wine
berries to make
wine wine forest went deep did we talk
about that we didn't talk about that oh
we did yeah
forest went beyond the edge yep i did
have
and you can follow me personally at tim
cast uh you want to shout out anything
first yeah so uh for our digital
publications is recoilweb.com and
offgridweb.com and then if you go to gun
digest
the gun digest website that is where you
can pre-order our diy
firearms book we are running out so get
there quick my personal instagram is at
fox row underscore official f-o-x-r-o-e
it's the only nickname that really stuck
and uh but yeah and by recall if you
wanna if you wanna see
some of the stuff we're doing
subscription is the best way to do it
but uh yeah i'm happily here to
answer questions about firearms and do
what i do cool always awesome to see you
man
yeah hey follow me in crossland you guys
rock thank you for coming uh ian
crossland.net if you wanna check out my
website and get a little portal into all
my socials but otherwise
at ian crossland hit me up anywhere
thanks and you guys i do have to issue a
clarification what i said earlier about
opals and mayonnaise
and the connection there with opals are
colloid not a suspension
mayonnaise is a suspension because it's
a liquid in a liquid so you guys should
look it up and educate yourselves on
that opals are fascinating other gems
are also very beautiful
a really cool chemistry background you
guys can follow me on twitter
at sour patch lids as i attempt to have
more followers and sour patch kids
thanks for hanging out everybody we'll
see you tomorrow at youtube.com
cast castle and after that we'll be back
monday for this show at 8pm
have a good weekend bye guys
you